danke herr präsident meine damen und
herren aus der regierungsbank
geschätzte abgeordnete kollegen vor
allem aber lieber österreicherinnen und
österreicher die sie heute diese ich
möchte sagen historische debatte und das
wird es wahrscheinlich auch sein zuhause
mitverfolgen ich sage es ihnen so wie es
ist ich sage es ihnen ganz ohne
umschweife ich bin entsetzt ich bin
fassungslos
ich bin erschüttert und ich bin
schockiert angesichts dessen was die
bundesregierung bestehend aus svp und
grünen gemeinsam mit ihren steigbügel
heute an einer schein opposition hier
und heute im rahmen des impfpflicht
gesetzes auf den weg bringen will und
ich gehe davon aus dass es in diesem
land gegenwärtig millionen von menschen
gibt die genauso empfinden wie ich das
tue und ich werde ihnen sagen warum
einfach deshalb weil diese einführung
einer impfpflicht das ist ja in wahrheit
nichts anderes als ein impfzwang weil
das nichts anderes ist als ein
gigantischer anschlag auf die freiheit
der österreicherinnen und österreicher
und weil es
und weil es ein regelrechtes attentates
möchte ich sagen auf die menschenwürde
der österreichischen bevölkerung geplant
und vorbereitet worden ist das alles
ganz akribisch von einer
verantwortungslosen
bundesregierung unter dem kommando eines
verantwortungslosen bundeskanzlers hand
in hand mit einem verantwortungslosen
gesundheitsminister das ist diejenige
regierung von der die menschen außerhalb
der mauern dieses parlaments oder
außerhalb ihrer ministerien längst sagen
das ist die schlechteste und kaltherzig
sste regierung ist die österreich je
gehabt hat
umgesetzt
umgesetzt man könnte auch sagen
abgenickt wird dieses gesetz von
abgeordneten der svp und der grünen
ebenso verantwortungslos von
abgeordneten die vergessen haben dass
dieses parlament hier keine verlängerte
werkbank für ministerien ist die
vergessen haben dass sie ein gelöbnis
auf die österreichische bundesverfassung
abgegeben haben und die offenbar dieses
hohe haus verwechseln mit einer
vollversammlung von pharma lobbyisten
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren und
das kommt noch erschwerend hinzu
willfährig unterstützt werden diese
verantwortungslosen akteure von ebenso
verantwortungslosen abgeordneten von
sogenannten oppositionsparteien namens
sp und neos meine damen und herren ich
habe das gefühl sie befinden sich in
geiselhaft ihrer beiden
parteivorsitzenden zwei damen die für
eine ganz ganz billige nebenrolle alles
opfern was ihrer partei heilig ist für
eine nebenrolle in einem jämmerlichen
regierung schauspiel werden die eigenen
grundsätze über bord geworfen wir haben
die eigenen wähler die eigenen
mitglieder die eigenen funktionäre unter
eigene klub verraten da können sie sich
wirklich gratulieren
meine damen und herren
diese impfpflicht das ist ein akt der
entrechtung da werden mit einem schlag
millionen österreicherinnen und
österreicher down geredet würde man auf
neudeutsch sagen sie sind keine
eigenständigen keine souveränen menschen
mehr sondern sie kommen auf die stufe
von befehlsempfänger von unterworfenen
von knechten von leibeigenen hätte
wahrscheinlich herr schallenberg ihr
vorgänger unseligen angedenkens gesagt
mit dieser impfpflicht meine damen und
herren wird in österreich dem portal
etat riss muss der weg bereitet es ist
nichts anderes ist die einführung des
gesundheits kommunismus und das ist ein
treppenwitz der geschichte dass wir zur
bekämpfung eines chinesischen wie
rustock chinesische gesellschaftsmodell
in österreich einführen das ist so
vieles auszeichnet aber nicht nur
freiheit und demokratie
totalitarismus das was der einzelne
wilders zählt nicht mehr es zählt nur
mal das was für die masse gut ist und
das was für die masse gut ist dass
werden uns in zukunft kapazunder vom
format eines jahren gesundheitsminister
mückstein vorgeben die werden und sagen
was für die masse gut ist und derjenige
der sich nicht daran hält wir verfolgt
wie ein krimineller
meine damen und herren das ist ein
türöffner für dilettantismus und willkür
gleichermaßen und kann niemals die
freiheitliche zustimmung finden und ich
sage ihnen ganz ehrlich ich schäme mich
heute an dieser stelle und an diesem
rednerpult für die abgeordneten der fdp
und der grünen und ich schäme mich für
die abgeordneten der neos und der
sozialdemokratie die das hier alles
durchziehen wollen sie das durchziehen
wollen in ihrer verbrennung ohne
rücksicht auf verluste und ich schäme
mich im übrigen auch für diejenigen die
nicht den mut gefunden haben eine
abweichende meinung hier im parlament
bei der abstimmung zu vertreten sondern
lieber zu hause zu bleiben unter
irgendwelchen fadenscheinigen ausreden
und meine damen und herren zugleich bin
ich stolz zugleich bin ich sehr sehr
stolz darauf klubobmann und partei
obmann der freiheitlichen fraktion hier
in diesem haus zu sein weil wir die
einzigen sind die bei diesem ersten
nicht mitmachen weil wir ihren
totalitären anwandlungen die stirn
bieten weil wir dagegen stimmen und weil
wir damit ohne wenn und aber die
freiheit der österreichischen
bevölkerung verteidigen und mit ihr die
verfassung und mit ihr die wahrheit
plant
wissen sie mich überrascht dass kornett
dass sie die negative entwicklung so
weit getrieben haben dass es soweit
gekommen ist dass wir heute an diesem
punkt stehen und ich werde ihnen sagen
warum denken sie zurück an den dezember
2020 damals hat die freiheitliche partei
eine petition gegen den impfzwang in
diesem land ins leben gerufen das war
zwei wochen bevor sie mit ihrer
inszenierung begonnen haben und wir
haben das deshalb gemacht weil wir
alarmiert waren und weil wir schockiert
waren ob der verbissenheit und ob da dem
fanatismus den sie an den tag gelegt
haben als es darum ging diese impfung
als ausschließlichen game changer in die
öffentlichkeit zu bringen und alles
andere für unzulässig zu erklären das
hat uns alarmiert und das hat uns
wachsam gemacht und wir haben der
bevölkerung gesagt ihr werdet schon
sehen achtung was auf es läuft auf einen
impfzwang hinaus alles andere sind nur
vorstufen und am ende steht die totale
macht für eine bundesregierung und auf
der anderen seite das totale
ausgeliefert sein und die totale
ohnmacht für die österreichische
bevölkerung das haben wir gesagt und
dafür sind wir verunglimpft worden
verächtlich gemacht worden und diese
bundesregierung und mit ihr natürlich
die mainstream medien wie sollst ein
anderes sein die haben uns als lügner
bezeichnet und viel mehr noch es ist
vielmehr noch passiert die vertreter
dieser bundesregierung haben stein und
bein geschworen dass es niemals soweit
kommen wird es wird keinen impfzwang
geben und ich habe in einer ein paar
zitate zur auffrischung zum boosten
ihrer erinnerung mitgebracht kollegin
köstinger im april 21 wir wollen auf
jeden fall keine impfpflicht in
österreich der grüne gesundheitsminister
mückstein also ich bin gegen eine
impfpflicht weil ich glaube dass wir
damit nichts erreichen werden
vp-klubobmann länger hier im parlament
ich betone es es gibt keine impfpflicht
in diesem land und es wird sie auch
nicht geben ihr ehemaliger bundeskanzler
sebastian kurz weise sich noch erinnern
können wir haben in österreich keine
impfpflicht und das ist gut so
verfassungsministerien edtstadler eine
impfpflicht schließe ich kategorisch aus
die wird es nicht geben das sollen die
menschen selbst entscheiden und zu guter
letzt auf werner kogler natürlich nicht
fehlen ich schließe eine impfpflicht aus
einem keller generelle impfpflicht
schließe ich tatsächlich aus ja meine
damen und herren und sechs steht diese
impfpflicht vor der tür in wenigen
stunden wollen sie sie hier herinnen
beschließen uns jetzt frage ich sie wer
hat hier die unwahrheit gesagt und wäre
die bevölkerung belogen und wer hat der
bevölkerung reinen wein eingeschenkt und
wer hat dir die wahrheit gesagt jeder
jede dieser aussagen die ich zitiert
habe jeder einzelne und das waren bei
weitem nicht alle ist ein einziger stich
in das herz ihrer glaubwürdigkeit sie
sind in der zwischenzeit verblutet bus
direkt würdigkeit betrifft und meine
damen und herren sehen sie das ist das
problem dieser bundesregierung das
nichts übrig geblieben von dieser
glaubwürdigkeit nach zwei jahren so
genannter pandemie bekämpfung und jetzt
verstehe ich schauen dass sie das
ausblenden von seiten der svp und der
grünen aber dass das den eos und das
dass der swr nicht auffällt das
verwundert dann doch einigermaßen sie
vertrauen jetzt denen die in wenigen
stunden gemeinsam mit ihnen das
beschließen was sie ein jahr lang
ausgeschlossen haben und sie vertrauen
damit denjenigen die sie belogen haben
und ihnen jetzt erklären dass der soll
es notwendig ist der einzige weg aus der
krise und so weiter und so weiter ja
meine damen und herren das kann doch
nicht ihr ernst sein als selbstbewusste
vertreter einer oppositionspartei das
gibt's doch nicht möchte ich meinen
glauben sie wirklich dass die leute
draußen vor den mauern des parlaments
dass die wirklich nicht wissen was
außerhalb der grenzen österreichs
gegenwärtig passiert dass die nicht
wissen dass in großbritannien die
maßnahmen auslaufen das schweden ohne
diese quälerei und sicherheit der
eigenen bevölkerung besser lieber
kollege wirklich besser durch die krise
gekommen ist als österreich und klagen
sie wirklich dass die leute nicht wissen
dass die tschechen gerade ihre pläne zur
impfpflicht einstampfen das ist
epidemiologischer sondermüll des landes
auf der altlasten deponie meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren und die
menschen bekommen das mit und wenn sie
es mir nicht glauben dann darf ich ihnen
einen nachrichtensender zitieren n tv
ich hoffe es ist gut genug ich hoffe es
ist in ihren faktenchecks nicht auch
schon ein schwul sender ich zitiere die
mikrowelle ist gewaltig doch verblüffend
ungefährlich spanien großbritannien
dänemark und die schweiz wollen das
virus bereits wie eine krippe behandeln
zitat ende und es wird noch
interessanter für sie die virologischen
galionsfiguren ihrerseits die herrn
falsche und rosten die freundinnen auch
schon in den rücken sie gehen in eine
ähnliche richtung wie diejenigen die sie
jahrelang beschimpft haben sie sagen
ihnen die bande miete zu ende und am
ende wird es so sein wie eine grippe was
heißt das events mäßig was heißt dass
das virus wird immer ungefährlicher die
impfung wird immer unwirksam und sie
kommen genau zu diesem zeitpunkt daher
mit dem vorschlag in österreich einen
impfzwang einzuführen da auch das muss
man erst einmal kommen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren auf das nur
erst einmal kommen während alle anderen
die maßnahmen abschaffen wollen sie von
18 jahren begonnen bis zur großen halle
in die nadel treiben das ist wirklich
ein stück wahnsinn dass sie heute auf
den weg bringen und meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren ich möchte mich an
dieser stelle an die abgeordneten der
einzelnen clubs wänden geschätzte
abgeordneter der grünen frau kollegin
maurer verlieren sie nie mehr ein wort
was heißt ein wort verlieren sie nie
mehr eine silbe im zusammenhang mit
datenschutz dem ober für die grünen in
diesem zusammenhang unterlassen sie in
sukow unterlassen sie in zukunft jede
kritik gegenüber einer individuellen
zielfahndung auf richterliche anordnung
im kampf gegen einzelne kriminelle oder
gegen die organisierte kriminalität wenn
sie heute zu einer rasterfahndung ihre
zustimmung geben wo millionen gesunde
menschen ins visier der polizei unter
gesundheitsbehörden geraten ohne dass
man ihnen irgendetwas vorwerfen kann von
ihrer position zur gentechnik rede ich
gar nicht mehr auch hier hat sich ihre
glaubwürdigkeit in luft aufgelöst und es
werden einige bei den grünen heute noch
ein elementares erlebnis haben wenn sie
nämlich sehen werden dass sie in
wahrheit feinde der freiheit und freunde
des totalitarismus sind geschätzte
abgeordnete der sp
ich würde an ihrer stelle noch einmal
darüber nachdenken ob es wirklich ein
gutes argument ist zu sagen die
regierung hat alles verbockt in corona
management sie hat was sagt wo man nur
versagen kann und deswegen unterstützen
wir jetzt die versager bei ihrem größten
versagen nämlich bei der einführung der
impfpflicht was ist denn das für ein
argument
ich hätte doch kein gutes gefühl aber es
passt in die linie ihres roten
vordenkers in wien der jetzt den
ungeimpften auch noch den arbeitsplatz
wegnehmen will ja meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren das ist die neue linie
der sozialdemokratie
arbeitsplatzvernichtung wohlstands
vernichtung schutz der arbeitnehmer in
diesem land doch seien die menschen
wissen an die adresse der neos frau
kollegin maria simon ihrem programm
heißt so schön im zweifel für die
freiheit wunderbar formuliert wir haben
sie denn überhaupt keine zweifel
haben sie denn überhaupt keine zweifel
bei dem was du auf den weg gebracht wird
das kann ich gar nicht glauben was ich
glauben kann ist dass sie bereit sind
die freiheit aufzuopfern damit sie den
mächtigen gefallen das kann ich glaube
das kann man auch machen weil wir essen
ja das kann man auch machen
aber den anspruch den anspruch stellen
gleichzeitig parteiobfrau einer
liberalen partei zu sein das geht sich
dann nicht mehr aus das geht sich dann
nicht mehr aus lesen sie lesen sich als
opfer über die offene gesellschaft und
ihre feinde ich glaube es wird für sie
eine erhellende lektüre sein und was die
abgeordneten der övp betrifft ja
vielleicht denken sie auch noch einmal
darüber nach ob es wirklich die adäquate
interpretation von christlicher
nächstenliebe ist wenn man millionen
menschen in die verzweiflung treibt wenn
man sie in sorge und in angst versetzt
wenn man sie kriminalisiert oder zu
bürgern zweiter klasse machen will nur
weil ein paar aus ihrer führungsebene
weiter den tanz um das goldene kalb aus
kontrolle geld und macht tanzen wollen
denken sie darüber nach in der
verbliebenen zeit und jetzt
ich fürchte dass der show alles nichts
nützt ich fürchte dass das alles nichts
nützt ich fühlte dass sie heute die
mehrheit haben werden bei dieser
abstimmung aber dieser
abstimmungserfolge unter
anführungszeichen das wird sie nicht
glücklich machen und das sage ich ihnen
einfach deshalb weil echte zufriedenheit
und glück niemals aufgebaut sein kann
auf dem leid und auf der unfreiheit von
millionen menschen das zeigt ihnen ein
blick in die geschichtsbücher
und das werden sie selbst am eigenen
leib zu spüren bekommen das prophezeit
ihnen schon heute wir freiheitliche
bleiben heute in der minderheit aber nur
hier erinnern bei draußen mit den
menschen die inzwischen unzufrieden sind
mit ihren maßnahmen da haben wir längst
die mehrheit und diese mehrheit die wir
täglich größer und das sage ich lieber
auf das sage ich ihnen
mit diesen menschen und das ist ein
versprechen von mir aus an dieser stelle
mit diesen menschen werden wir die
impfpflicht auf jeden fall zum kippen
bringen unter ausnutzung ihrer eigenen
bürokratie sie werden sich noch wundern
wir werden sie zu fall bringen unter
berufung auf die gerichte in allen
instanzen und nicht nur in österreich
und wir werden sie vor allem zu fall
bringen durch demokratische wahlen
sie werden als ja-sager von heute ihrer
gerechten strafe morgen nicht entkommen
das wird ihnen weder moralisch noch
rechtlich noch politisch gelingen und
das können sie mir glauben im
unterschied zu ihnen pflege ich meine
versprechen einzuhalten
im übrigen auch dasjenige das sich
selbstverständlich weiterhin ungeimpft
bleiben werde auch wenn sie mich so wie
millionen österreicher dazu zwingen
beugen
[Musik]
am wort ist doch sie geht maurer bitte
der club ab
sehr geehrter herr präsident
sehr geehrte bundesregierung die
mitglieder der bundesregierung auf der
regierungsbank liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen aber vor allem liebe
zuseherinnen und zuseher
wir treten hier heute tatsächlich glaube
ich zu einem recht außergewöhnlichen
tagesordnungspunkt zusammen die korona
pandemie hat uns seit märz 20 20 laufend
vor neue herausforderungen gestellt
und auch jede und jeden einzelnen von
uns hier im hohen haus aber insbesondere
natürlich insbesondere jeden einzelne
jede einzelne die hier in österreich
lebt die mit dieser pandemie
konfrontiert ist und mit den vielen
einschränkungen die damit verbunden sind
auf eine harte probe gestellt
zentral für die bewältigung
dieser pandemie
warnung sind umsichtiges und
vorsichtiges handeln aber vor allem
eines gesellschaftlicher zusammenhalt
seit dezember 20 20 gibt es impfstoffe
gegen das krone virus sie sind
mittlerweile milliardenfach verimpft es
gibt sehr sehr viele studien dazu wir
wissen dass sie sicher sind und wir
wissen dass sie wirken
diese impfstoffe schützen unsere
gesundheit und sie schützen unsere
mitmenschen sie sorgen dafür dass wir
milde verläufe haben dass wir weniger
ansteckend sind dass weniger menschen
ins krankenhaus kommen weniger menschen
auf den intensivstationen landen weniger
menschen an diesen virus sterben
und wer auch hier in diesem hohen haus
die wirkung der info leugnet kann das
nicht ohne schlechten hintergedanken tun
und ich möchte an dieser stelle schon
sagen klubobmann kickl sie haben hier
gefragt wer hat hier die wahrheit gesagt
sie waren es ganz sicher nicht und dass
sie auch noch stolz darauf
dass sie auch noch stolz sind darauf und
darauf verweisen dass die 20 20 die
menschen aufgerufen haben sich nicht
impfen zu lassen
und stolz sind darauf menschen
abgehalten haben abgehalten zu haben
dass sie sich selbst und ihre
mitmenschen stützen
das ist
letztklassig es ist unsinn
diese ihre politik ist auch ein grund
für die niedrige impfquote die wir nach
wie vor haben und ihr verhalten ist
absolut zynisch gegenüber allen menschen
die an diesem virus gestorben und
gegenüber all den angehörigen kiefern
menschen schämen sich
aber wir sind hier heute im haus
versammelt um den aus weg zu beschreiten
aus dieser pandemie um wieder
zurückzukommen zu unserem gewohnten
leben zu einem leben ohne die
einschränkungen die uns seit zwei jahren
fast begleiten ohne lok tanz ohne die
psychischen folgen die es für die
jugendlichen und kinder hat wenn sie
nicht in der schule in den kindergarten
kennen können wir wollen zurück zu
unserem normalen leben ohne die
einschränkung unserer freiheit
die impfpflicht die wir heute hier mit
einer ganz ganz großen parlamentarischen
mehrheit beschließen werden ist der weg
aus dieser pandemie
vor zwei jahren hätte sich niemand von
uns gedacht dass wir es jemals mit
dieser kranken zu tun haben werden die
uns jetzt schon ein dreiviertel jahr auf
trab hält niemand hätte gedacht also ich
erinnere die alpha welle wir dachten das
ist schlimm waren kam delta wenn man
diese wellen miteinander vergleicht was
die zahl der toten betrifft was die zahl
der hospitalisierungen
betrifft die menschen auf den
intensivstationen und damit auch da
unten natürlich das personal auf diesen
intensivstationen wir haben das nicht
gewusst jetzt kann die omikron variante
auch die von der haben wir auch zwei
jahre vor zwei jahren nichts gewusst
heute stellen wir uns dieser
herausforderung einmal mehr und wir
waren diesen entschlossenen schritt zur
einführung einer impfpflicht damit ihr
zurückkommen können zu unseren gewohnten
nehmen wir haben diesen beschluss
gefasst weil wir die impfquote erhöhen
müssen damit wir wieder normal leben
können mit der impfung schützen wir uns
selbst und wir schützen unsere
mitmenschen und wir sorgen dafür dass
wir keine weiteren lockt uns brauchen
wir alle die heute dieser impfpflicht
zustimmen werden haben es uns ganz
sicher nicht leicht gemacht und ja das
ist durchaus richtig niemand von uns
wollte eine impfpflicht wir waren
überzeugt davon dass wir es schaffen
können auch so die menschen zu
überzeugen dass sie sich impfen lassen
müssen leider gibt es eine
mobilisierende kraft die das interesse
und die gesundheit der menschen in
österreich nicht im blick kam sondern
nur politisches kleingeld
wir haben im november beschlossen diese
im pflicht einzuführen und wir haben uns
viel zeit dafür genommen sehr intensive
gespräche geführt mit medizinerinnen und
medizinern mit verfassungsjuristen und
verfassungsjuristen wir haben einen
begutachtungsentwurf
entwickelt gemeinsam mit der
sozialdemokratie und den eos und
da habe ich ein sehr einen sehr guten
begutachtungsentwurf zustande gebracht
es haben sehr viele stellungnahmen
wurden eingeholt und eingebracht auch
für diese teilnehmen möchte ich mich
herzlich bedanken
und wir haben jetzt nach ende der
begutachtung viele änderungen
eingearbeitet und ganz genau angeschaut
was wurde rückgemeldet und das gesetz
noch einmal angepasst
und ich möchte mich an dieser stelle
ganz ausdrücklich bedanken bei
parteichefin pamela rendi-wagner bei
parteichefin bärte meine reisinger
selbstverständlich auch bei dem
koalitionspartner övp
dafür dass diese wirklich extrem
konstruktive zusammenarbeit möglich war
und so gut funktioniert hat und an
dieser stelle möchte ich auch diesen
dank erweitern auch die mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter im hintergrund das waren
beispielsweise auf seiten der neos alexa
am inn hübner auf seitens auf seite der
spd jochen preis und gaby kotter und es
war selbstverständlich auf ministerialer
seite
bundeskanzleramt verfassungsdienst aber
vor allem natürlich im
gesundheitsministerium michael hörmann
das team und die sektion die die große
herausforderung einen sauberen runden
gesetzestext zu produzieren wirklich
zusammen zustande
ich bin hier die erste rednerin zu
diesem gesetzentwurf und ich möchte ein
paar eckpunkte trotzdem noch erläutern
was haben wir gemacht oder was man
werden wir tun mit anfang februar wird
das impfpflicht gesetz in kraft treten
es verfolgt dann ein schreiben an alle
haushalte in dem wir noch einmal darüber
informieren was das konkret bedeutet
umfasst von der impfpflicht sind alle
personen ab 18 jahren aufgenommen sind
schwangere aufgenommen sind genesene
personen für ein halbes jahr nach der
positiven pcr test und menschen die sich
aus medizinischen gründen nicht impfen
lassen können mit 15 märz wird es dann
so sein dass bei normalen kontrollen
beispielsweise verkehrskontrollen oder
kontrollen zur einhaltung der kroner
maßnahmen auch der impfstatus abgefragt
werden kann von der polizei wenn er
nicht erbracht werden kann vor ort
erfolgt eine anzeige bei der
verwaltungsbehörde des wohn des
hauptwohnsitzes und dann hat man zwei
wochen zeit entweder den impfstatus
nachzuliefern oder einen ausnahme con
vorzubringen erfolgt das nicht dann wird
bestraft
das ziel dieser impfpflicht ist die
impfquote massiv zu erhöhen und ich bin
zuversichtlich dass uns das gelingen
kann die impfung ist der weg aus dieser
pandemie da weg zurück in die freiheit
um in ein leben ohne beschränkungen
das ziele impfung ist nicht die
bestrafung sondern möglichst viele
möglichst alle menschen davon zu
überzeugen sich impfen zu lassen
weil wir wissen damit können wir die
pandemie bewältigen die impfung ist auch
ein siegeszug der wissenschaft gegen die
leugnung von fakten und empirie im
schnitt auch ein solidarischer akt seien
sie solidarisch liebe zuseherinnen und
zuseher und ich freue mich dass wir das
hier nach seinem großen gemeinsamen
kraftakt heute beschließen können vielen
dank
zu einer tatsächlichen berichtigung
magister jörg leichtfried bitteschön
abgeordnete
sehr geehrte damen und herren daher
abgeordnete kickl hat
behauptet wird versorgung skurrilerweise
behauptet die fpö wäre die einzige
partei die die wahrheit behauptet und am
meisten wahrheit verkündet in dieser
bande milch darf die frau berlakovich
zitieren die sagt in den spitälern sind
mehr menschen mit impfschäden dass wir
menschen die an kubica erkrankt sind
muss ihnen schon sagen so viele
unwahrheiten soviel geschwurbel vom
pferd den wohnungsmieter bis zu
vitaminpräparaten die zu nehmen sind ist
von keiner anderen partei gekommen
deshalb ist diese aussage vollkommen
unrichtig
statt die klubobleute in dem
parlamentsklub versuchen gemeinsam mit
den mandaten wieder die frage
tatsächlichen berichtigung durchzugehen
damit auch wieder der geschäftsordnung
zum durchbruch verholfen wird dann wird
man gestern gerd kann ja kritischen
abgeordneten
danke sehr herr präsident sehr geehrte
mitglieder der bundesregierung gesetzte
abgeordneten und abgeordnete kolleginnen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer ja
die ist das gesamte krisen-management
der jetzigen bundesregierung ist eine
anreihung von
versäumnissen
fehleinschätzungen
falsche versprechungen und auch
verfassungsbrüche denn man braucht sich
nur die entscheidungen des
verfassungsgerichtshofs der letzten
eineinhalb jahre ansehen und man wird
unzählige verordnungen und gesetze
dieser bundesregierung unter dem
deckmantel des krisenmanagements finden
die nicht verfassungskonform waren und
heute hier soll das impfpflicht gesetz
beschlossen werden ein weiteres gesetz
was aus unserer sicht ganz klar
verfassungswidrig ist
das imk gesetz stellt in gewisser
hinsicht den höhepunkt einer eskalation
für miete darin die bundesregierung im
krisen management gefahren ist und es
hat dafür gesorgt dass wir hier mit den
bisher schwersten eingriffen in die
grund und freiheitsrechte von unserer
bürger konfrontiert sind es hat dafür
gesorgt dass
einmalig in der zweiten republik über
400.000 negative stellungnahmen und
zustimmungen zustellung haben im rahmen
des begutachtungsverfahrens eingegangen
sind und es hat dafür gesorgt dass
zehntausende menschen in österreich
woche für woche auf die straße gehen um
gegen diesen wahnsinn der
bundesregierung zu demonstrieren
doch meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren hier reagiert die bundesregierung
auf diese sorgen und ängste der bürger
in dem eine bannmeile um das parlament
errichtet wird das mit man bloß nicht in
den kontakt mit kritischen bürgern kommt
ja genau so ist das ja in dem an dem
gesetzesvorhaben natürlich in keinster
weise von diesem gesetz deshalb in
keinster weise abgegangen wird sondern
ein es wird dann auch noch in einzelnen
bereichen verschärft man erschwert es
den menschen ausnahme gründen geltend zu
machen man erschwert es den menschen ein
spruch im verwaltungsverfahren zu
erheben mannschaft ein
verschlechterungsverbot im rahmen des
einspruches ab und man sorgt für noch
ein paar zusätzliche
verordnungsermächtigungen wenn ein
bundesminister ich bin ja wirklich
entsetzt die bundesregierung nennt
dieses gesetz so harmlos in freimann
gesetz in wirklichkeit ist es ein
impfpflicht ermächtigungsgesetz für den
gesundheitsminister meine sehr geehrten
damen und dran denn er kann alleine
entscheiden wer sich wie oft mit was
hinterlassen muss wer wie oft mit wem
was tun darf im endeffekt habe ich ja
fast den eindruck dass im rahmen dieser
verordnungsermächtigung das gesamte
recht nicht mehr vom volk ausgeht und
die gesetzgebung nicht mehr vom
parlament ausgehen sondern
ausschließlich von diversen ministerien
so kann es ja wohl wirklich nicht sein
meine sehr geehrten haben
aber wie ist es denn überhaupt zu diesen
impfpflicht gesetz gekommen und da gab
es dieses ominöse treffen am 29 30
november vergangenen jahres
wo die regierung wieder einmal
konfrontiert war mit der nicht mit dem
nicht rechtzeitigen agieren in
anbetracht der bevorstehenden
del-tabelle im herbst und man hat sich
sagen typisch österreichisch und ganz
pragmatisch einfach darauf geeinigt zwei
versprechen zu brechen nämlich das
versprechen dass es keinen allgemeinen
lockdown mehr gehen wird und das
versprechen dass es keine allgemeine
impfpflicht gehen wird das ist das
krisen-management der bundesregierung im
vergangenen herbst gewesen und die
folgen dürfen hierzu alle ausbaden
was soll denn das ziel dieser ominösen
impfpflicht sein der die bundesregierung
erfüllt im gesetz die bringen zur
verhinderung der ausbreitung von gas co2
und zum schutz vor überlastung des
gesundheitswesen nun mittlerweile sind
sich tatsächlich alle experten einig
dass die vorhandenen impfstoffe keine
sterile immunität bieten dass es mit
ihnen nicht möglich ist so wie wir das
bei anderen impfungen durchaus der fall
wie bei masern mumps röteln und co das
ist nicht möglich ist mit den kopien
stoff und dieser zeit verhalten ist
dieses virus auszulöschen oder auch nur
die epidemische ausbreitung irgendwo
signifikant zu beeinflussen das heißt
dieses ziel der einbremsen der epidemie
ist von haus aus nicht erreichbar mit
den vorhandenen impfstoff und damit auch
nicht mit einer impfpflicht
bleibt das argument einer überlastung
des gesundheitswesens ja
gegen die ursprünglichen varianten und
auch noch eingeschränkt gegen die data
variante konter von den herstellern in
den studien gezeigt werden dass ein
gewisser schutz vor schweren
krankheitsverläufen besteht wohl gleich
die studienlage gezeigt hat dass dieser
schutz recht rasch abnimmt und vor allem
bei der omicron variante viel schwächer
ausgeprägt ist und noch viel schneller
abnimmt und die mehrfach musterung nicht
mehr den effekt hat wie er hofft deshalb
haben die israelis auch die vierte den
vierten stich abgebrochen und forcieren
das gar nicht weiter wir wollen dafür
die vierter fünfter sechster siebter im
von gesetzlichen der bundesminister das
ist ja vollkommen widersinnig
überhaupt
omikron ist ja tatsächlich ein grosser
game changer denn diese neue virus
variante ist zwar deutlich ansteckender
aber wie wir selbst als das eigene
zahlen wissen und aus den ländern wo die
mikrowelle bereits durchgerauscht ist
wissen wir dass erstens einmal diese
welle vollkommen unabhängig von der
durchimpfungsrate der jeweiligen
bevölkerung innerhalb von sechs wochen
rauf und wieder runter geht wir wissen
dass die hospitalisierung raten maximal
ein viertel von dem sind was sie bei
data rahn wir wissen dass die
intensivmedizinische
intensivmedizinische belag maximal ein
fünftel von dem ist was es bei delta war
ja wo ist denn da die notwendigkeit dass
sie genau jetzt
zusätzliche einschränkungen der grund-
und freiheitsrechte und dann
unmittelbaren impfzwang verankern wollen
das ist ja überhaupt nicht
argumentierbar
[Applaus]
ich möchte aber jetzt gar nicht weiter
auch auf die rechtlichen und
zugänglichkeit 'nen dieses geplant
nämlich gesetzes eingehen ich möchte nur
ganz pragmatisch in den raum stellen wie
wie wollen sie denn dieses gesetz
tatsächlich umsetzen sie wollen es jetzt
in kraft treten lassen sie haben die
ausnahmebestimmungen so stark
eingeschränkt dass jeder ungeimpfte in
österreich der in sorge um seine
gesundheit ein ausnahme des hamburg
musste zum amtsarzt oder einem epidemie
arzt gehen muss ausgenommen aber
krebskranke die sich in
spitalsbehandlung befinden er wurde dass
minister wie soll das dann überhaupt
praktisch durchführbar sein für über 1,3
millionen und österreich oder lassen es
die hälfte sein wenn nur die hälfte
davon entsprechende gesundheitsgründe
geltend macht innerhalb der nächsten
zwei monate einen termin beim amtsarzt
zu bekommen überhaupt einmal als nicht
geimpfter und vielleicht nicht genesener
in eine ph eingelassen zu werden wir
dort haben sie nämlich in den meisten
fällen auch anzeige ihre china wie
sollen diese menschen dann überhaupt zu
ihrer befreiung sagt das kann man sie
schreiben eine ausnahmemöglichkeit vor
die für den großteil der bevölkerung ja
gar nicht erreichbar ist weiß ja nicht
einmal hinkommen zum abend sozusagen
termin dass sie die gesundheitlichen
beschwerden vorliegen können das ist ja
gar nicht praktikabel
das heißt eine neue ausnahme die sie
hier schaffen aber gleichzeitig die
strafandrohungen ab 15 märz mit der so
genannten phase zwei schienen sie nennen
das ganze in der phase 2 die
kontrollphase wobei sich die polizei und
die polizeigewerkschaften schon klar
geäußert haben dass sie diese kontrollen
nicht in ihrem auftrag durchführen
wollen weil sie für die schicke für die
schikane der bevölkerung nicht zuständig
sind sondern das ist eine aufgabe der
gesundheitsbehörde ist ich in eine reine
willkür phase wenn sie werden in dieser
phase bild kürlich genau diejenigen
strafen die ihnen unangenehm sein die
wir uns im rahmen von kontrollen dann
zusätzlich noch minim pflicht gesetz
bestrafen eine gerechte und
gleichwertige und und nicht
diskriminierender bestrafung wird es in
dieser phase gar nicht geben und dann
steht ja noch die ominöse phase 3 im
raum
die phase 3 in der sie dann die
rasterfahndung einsetzen wollen in der
sie die automatisierte bestrafung der
bevölkerung einführen wollen und in der
dann und das wissen sie aus dem
begutachtungsverfahren und der
stellungnahmen der verwaltungsrichter
eine absolute überlastung der behörden
und der verwaltungsgerichte drohen wird
so dass sie diese phase de facto gar nie
umsetzen werden können
herr bundesminister
ich habe es vorher schon mal gesagt
gehen sie in sich ja es gibt so viele
gute gründe warum wir dieses gesetz
jetzt nicht brauchen
es gibt so viele maßnahmen die sie in
der vergangenheit noch nicht gemacht
haben den kapazitätsausbau das schaffen
von frühzeitigen behandlungsoptionen
auch im niedergelassenen bereich die
sicherstellung dass jeder der krank zu
hause ist auch tatsächlich unmittelbar
haus herzlich betreut wird damit sie so
die hospitalisierung traten in griff
bekommen und dazu keine überlastung
kommt das alles haben sie vernachlässigt
und noch immer nicht gemacht jetzt haben
sie die chance dazu ziehen sie dieses
gesetz zurück
verstärken sie die alternativen
maßnahmen dann brauchen wir gar keine
mehr und sagen sie auch einmal dafür
dass überhaupt einmal die gesamte
immunität in der bevölkerung tatsächlich
erhoben wird denn wenn sie als ziel eine
90-prozentige durchimpfungsquote angeben
dann müssen sie auch einmal den beweis
antreten wie hoch die grund immunität in
der bevölkerung überhaupt schon bevor
sie mit gesetzlichen zwang daherkommen
und die leute zwei simulieren wollen
vielen dank
zu einer tatsächlichen berichtigung nun
ja abgeordneter alois stöger bitte schön
dass ich kenne die bestimmungen der
geschäftsordnung
[Applaus]
danke herr präsident
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler
vizekanzler liebe mitglieder der
bundesregierung
tatsächlichen berichtigung machen der
herr abgeordnete kg hat in seiner rede
behauptet
dass anführungszeichen das virus wird
immer ungefährlicher und die impfung
wird immer unwirksamer anführungszeichen
ende das ist unrichtig der richtige
sachverhalt richtige sachverhalt lautet
die impfung wirkt auch gegen romy cohen
hervorragend daten aus bouclé sagen 94
prozent schutz nach booster auch vor
hospitalisierung sehr geehrter herr
abgeordneter kiki ganz nette
österreichische bevölkerung
verunsichern es wäre notwendig dass man
sachlich und korrekt darauf hinweist
dass die impfung für die
österreicherinnen und österreicher gut
ist und dass das
ganz entscheidend für die gesundheit der
menschen in österreich ist
zur geschäftsordnung im hertener kck
britischen
sehr geehrter präsidenten den zweiten
fall der kollegen von der
sozialdemokratischen fraktion
in wahrheit des missbrauchs der
tatsächlichen berichtigung jetzt meinem
kollegen stöger noch evident da es beim
kollegen leichtfried ich weiß nicht was
das motiv ist möglicherweise zu viele
pusten damit ihre partei bei mir in die
wagner erst nach 15 uhr tragen kommt
alles andere ist mir nicht
nachvollziehbar ich ersuche sicher
präsident hier gegen diesen missbrauch
des instruments der tatsächlichen
berichtigung was zu unternehmen vielen
dank
zur geschäftsordnung bitteschön
hersteller akubat bitteschön zeigt
vielen dank herr präsident zu den
ausführungen des kollegen kasseckert
fischer anmerken dass scheinbar in den
reihen der freiheitlichen große
nervosität herrscht das wäre nicht
notwendig hier so ein theater zu
veranstalten dass ich es gemacht habe
ich kann nur sagen die sozialdemokratie
ist herausragend in der lage
tatsächliche berichtigungen zu machen
und herr präsident ist auch in der lage
diese sitzung ohne ihr zutun zu führen
dankeschön
[Applaus]
nun zu einer tatsächlichen berichtigung
verarbeiten jemals sie kennen die
bestimmungen der geschäfte besucher ganz
besonders darauf zu sagen besten dank
[Musik]
die tester
vielen dank herr präsident wert der
kolleginnen kollegen daher abgeordnete
kann jack hat in seiner rede büro
behauptet eine bannmeile wurde rund ums
parlament von der bundesregierung
eingerichtet ich berichte tatsächlich
das ist unrichtig das ist unrichtig
berichtigen tatsächlich dieses steht im
gesetz nämlich im versammlungsgesetz von
§
während der nationalrat der bundesrat
die bundesversammlung oder ein landtag
versammelt ist darf im umkreis von 300
metern von ihrem sitz keine versammlung
unter freiem himmel
stattfindet
zufrieden
an bord wäre jetzt die post ist der
toren patenten pamela rendi-wagner sie
haben eine redezeit von zehn minuten
vorgesehen ich müsste aber überreden
nach etwa ein bis zwei minuten
unterbrechen und ob sie fragen ob sie
erst danach sprechen wollen das ist der
fall ich unterbreche der herr die
sitzung bis 15 uhr
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ich nehme die unterbrochene sitzung
wieder auf wie gelangen zur kurzen
debatte über die anfragebeantwortung des
bundesministers für soziales gesundheit
pflege und konsumentenschutz mit der
ordnungszahl
8500 ab die erwähnte anfragebeantwortung
ist bereits verteilt worden so dass sich
eine verlesung durch die schriftführer
erübrigt wie geben in die die parteien
die ich mache darauf aufmerksam dass
gemäß § 57a absatz einzelne
geschäftsordnung kein redner länger als
fünf minuten sprechen davor bei dem
erster redner zur begründung eine
redezeit von zehn minuten zukommt
stellungnahmen von mitgliedern der
bundesregierung oder zum wort gemeldeten
staatssekretären sollen nicht länger als
zehn minuten dauern ich ersuche
abgeraten peter wurm als antragsteller
des verlangens die debatte zu eröffnen
die redezeit beträgt zehn minuten
bitte schön herr abgeordneter
wurde bitteschön abgeraten sie sind an
bord
ja danke herr präsident die
regierungsbank mit kanzler vizekanzler
frau kollegin rendi-wagner hof sie unter
verzeihen wir diese unterbrechung jetzt
aber ich glaube es passt ganz gut zum
thema ja wenn der bundeskanzler
dann wieder auftaucht und ihm jetzt
gratulieren zu seiner genesung er hat ja
als 35 der letzte woche krone gehabt und
der bundeskanzler hat daneben
verkündet vom home office aus
und das war das entscheidende eben er
dreifach geimpftes umfeld nur geimpfte
hat er sich hingestellt vor den
computern hat gesagt die impfung wirkt
ich bin das beste beispiel das war ein
original zitat von bundeskanzler und ich
würde vielleicht vergleichen mit
jemanden der aus dem zweiten stockwerk
springt sich beide beine bricht und im
krankenhaus behauptet ich kann fliegen
so ähnlich würde es in etwa vergleichen
erschütternd ist für mich als nicht dass
der bundeskanzler selber seine aussage
gemacht für mich ist erschütternd dass
millionen offensichtlich wirklich
glauben der bundeskanzler kann fliegen
wenn ich jetzt so auch die diskussion um
höhere und sie alle völlig negieren die
tatsachen wie eben alle mittlerweile
evident sind und wenn wir jetzt oder
wenn jemand gestern vielleicht servus tv
geschaut hat und den hoch informativen
berichten in schweden gesehen hat dann
möchte ich vielleicht auch hier noch
einmal für österreich ein paar dinge
klarstellen und zwar auch diese
verunglimpfung von menschen die einen
impfschaden in österreich eliten haben
finde ich schon sehr bedenklich weil das
sind menschen die sie quasi zu dieser
impfung gedrängt überzeugt haben die
haben wir guten gewissens auch diese
impfung gemacht haben dann massive
schwierigkeiten gehabt und deshalb
sollten gerade sie mit diesen menschen
sehr ehrfürchtig einmal umgehen und was
klar ist
was was kreis wir haben mittlerweile war
diese impfung hundertmal mehr meldungen
von nebenwirkungen wie bei allen anderen
impfungen bisher was auch klaus und ich
spreche immer von österreich wir haben
mehrere 200 todesfälle die im
zusammenhang im zeitlichen zusammenhang
mit dieser impfung stehen sind alles
keine keine erfindungen kann man sich
alles selber auch anschauen sind die
offiziellen augustzahlen
auch mittlerweile international gibt es
doch hinweise dass und das ist ganz
dramatisch kommen aber noch nicht
verifizieren dass im zeitlichen
zusammenhang mit der impfung vor allem
dritten in form mit der musterung auch
die todesrate offensichtlich parallel
mit wächst es wird noch untersucht aber
das ist in vielen ländern mittlerweile
evident ich habe im gesundheitsausschuss
als zweitlinien angemerkt erstens
sollten wir in österreich in der lage
sein gott diese impfschäden aktiv zur
verfolgung zu bearbeiten und nicht so
wie es derzeit passiert passiv passiv
heißt es muss jemand eine aktion setzen
und aktiv würde heißen man schaut
wirklich meinen ärzten boss passiert das
was die dunkelziffer ist dementsprechend
groß und das was ich von anfang an oder
wie das freiheitliche kritisiert haben
und da habe ich heute noch kein wort
gehört das ist dass die pharmafirmen
keinerlei haftung für ihn schäden
übernehmen und sie alle sich hier
herstellen und sorgen die impfung wirkt
und die impfung ist sicher und frei ist
warum übernehmen die pharmafirmen dann
keine haftung ein widerspruch in sich
und um das auch noch einmal
klarzustellen die positionen der
freiheitlichen wir haben immer gesagt es
muss die freiheit bestehen individuell
zu entscheiden
mit seinem arzt besprechen macht die
impfung für mich sie nicht sind wir
haben nie gesagt dass soll sich nicht
impfen lassen das ist schlichtweg eine
lüge sagt noch einmal wie immer nur
gesagt die freiwilligkeit muss bleiben
und wir haben auch nie bestritten dass
es corona gibt aber wir haben immer
darauf hingewiesen dass corona richtig
bestes und nicht die kohle reis und wenn
heute eben ihre sogenannten top
virologen jetzt plötzlich das als grippe
darstellen sondern erinnern was im
frühjahr 2020 hier in diesem haus an
echo erfolgt ist von ihnen als wir
ebenfalls das mit einer schweren
grippewelle verglichen haben
was war bisher noch einmal gestellt da
war klar die impfung schützt nicht vor
einer ansteckung die impfung schützt
ebenso nichts vor einer weitergabe des
virus und die impfung schützt auch nicht
vor dem krankenhaus
das war bisher jetzt beim e-tron ist
vollkommen klar jetzt werden die karten
komplett neu gemischt die impfung wirkt
nicht das haben im übrigen auch für
erklärungen für die anderen abgeordneten
ihre eigenen experten partei experten im
gesundheitsausschuss genauso ausgeführt
also das sollten sie an einer
tatsächlichen berichtigung vielleicht
nicht einführen weil dann führen sie
sich selber ad absurdum bei ohne grund
ist auch klar soweit die ersten zahlen
zeigen dass sogar
überproportional stark doppelt und
dreifach geimpfte an omikron an grenzen
und wenn sie im bekannten
verwandtenkreis in der firma herr
umfragen bei uns ist ja selber leben und
die österreicher bekommen sie mit dass
plötzlich jene die 2 und 3 fach kind
sind mikron haben ist ja nichts neues
der bundeskanzler dass er das beste
beispiel dafür was überhaupt vergessen
wird ist die frage der genesenen möchte
noch einmal darauf hinweisen da gibt es
ganz wenig studien auch in österreich
leider das bild zu wenig die schweiz
hat einen status von zwölf monate bei
genesenen wir noch sechs monate
deutschland offen diese drei monate also
den wissenschaftler zusammenhang in
diesen drei deutschsprachigen länder
muss mir auch mal einer erklären
das gesundheitssystem ist überlastet wie
komme ich erinnern wollen eine heiße
diskussion der berühmte stufenplan herr
minister von 1 bis 5 wir sind aktuell
von den bewegungen im krankenhaus bei
der stufe 1 und die maßnahmen in der
stufe 5 soweit zu ihrer glaubwürdigkeit
zu ihrem events basierten politikum zu
allem was sie immer auch den menschen
draußen erzählen das passt hinten und
vorne nicht zusammen
es wirkt es wirkt vielleicht einige
geben die die entwicklung der letzten
beiden jahre in österreich gut finden es
gibt ja so krank ist ihnen das gefällt
offensichtlich aber ich glaube schon
dass die mehrheit der bevölkerung
mittlerweile egal wie malst du kroner
selber steht im funk procontra glaube
ich alle einen dramatischen verfall
unseres staates erlebt haben also auch
der verlust an glaubwürdigkeit in alle
instanzen und das ist eine ganz
dramatische entwicklung und kann dort
noch mal darauf hinweisen das müssen wir
schnellstmöglich beenden also ich sehe
das schon von den kollateralschäden ich
gehe ja gar nicht von den ominösen 100
milliarden euro die wir alle zahlen
werden müssen vor allem der normale
grüber draußen bis zu den diversen look
tanz und anderen dingen
im status wenn ich heute irgendwo
hingehen mir ein hemd kaufen dann
kontrolliert mit die polizei ich brauche
was ihr ganzes dokumentenmappe limit
also wenn das das ist wo sie hinwollen
früher hat martina m ausgelacht wir
haben mittlerweile kennen wir haben
dieses soziale wenn du dich gut verhält
und bekommt der punkt der so ähnlich
läuft mittlerweile und es kann doch
bildschirms ganz egal ob die impfung
hilft nicht da sein wo wir in österreich
hin wollen und diese spaltung der
gesellschaft die haben sie jetzt seit
zwei jahren befeuert ich möchte noch
einmal erinnern an die ganzen aussagen
die wir gefallen sind und nicht die
ungeimpften haben das befeuert und ich
glaube einfach ein einsatz sollte
wichtig sein für uns alle und das ist
schwierig genug wir sollten vergeben
können man sollte aber nicht vergessen
was passiert ist ist auch das ganz
bewusst sie haben mehrere rote linie
überschritten
für sie haben also so viel schaden
angerichtet bei der breiten bevölkerung
und vergeben ist gut aber vergessen
vergessen sollte es sollten wir alle
nicht wie weit wie weit diese regierung
mit ihrem beihilfen von espoo neos die
letzten zwei jahren gegangen sind wie
weit gegangen sei das sollten wir nicht
vergessen und wie dünn
diese schicht wie können diese schicht
ist aber verzeihen wird gut sein ja was
wir auch gesehen haben und das sage ich
ein bisschen provokant
mittlerweile
ich glaube ja an zufälle also sich ein
zufall dass die militärische dieser erde
ihr vermögen in den letzten zwei jahren
verdoppelt haben ist sicher ein zufall
würde ich nicht an zufälle glauben
möchte ich an das denken aber ich glaube
zufällig ganz wichtig sagt sie nur und
die zweite geschichte die wir auch
gelernt haben dass eine hohe frauenquote
eine hohen frauenquote der regierung und
wir haben die höchste frauenquote die
ihnen jemals hatten ersten sicherstellt
dass eine gute politik gemacht wird und
zweitens sicherstellt dass eine
menschliche politik gemacht wird beide
thesen glaube ich haben wir jetzt mit
dieser frauenquote in dieser regierung
eindeutig widerlegt ich sehe weder durch
eine hohen frauenquote eine menschliche
politik noch eine bessere politik also
den zusammenhang den zusammenhang muss
man erklären so ich bin überzeugt dass
wir am ende des tages das alles
überwinden werden ich bin überzeugt
davon dass die wahrheit die wahrheit und
das gute sehen wird diese spaltung in
der gesellschaft die sie heute mit
diesen impfpflicht gesetz umsetzen
werden
diese spaltung wie sie mit diesen ins
gesetz hier in österreich umgesetzt
haben die wird hoffentlich und ich bin
überzeugt davon bald ein ende finden
dass wir wieder eine echte normalität
kommen ohne diesen zwang ihrerseits
danke
zurückgeht ist bundesminister mit
steinen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident der geehrte
damen und herren habt gerade heute liebe
zuseherinnen und zuseher zu hause
zur kurz debatte beziehungsweise zur
beantwortung der frage von abgeordneten
wird sich bezüglich verzicht
aspiration bei internen muskuläre
injektion möchte ich folgendes sagen
evidenzbasierte empfehlungen zu
publizieren es mir als
gesundheitsminister als arzt ein
besonderes anliegen ich möchte diese
gelegenheit benutzen noch einmal darauf
hinzuweisen
dass alle evidenz dafür spricht dass die
coop 19 schimpfen und zwar alle in
österreich erhältlichen präparate sicher
sind
die
beantwortung dass der gegner gegen
ständigen anfrage
möchte ich so kommentieren was ist
aspiration bei einer inter muskulären
injektion man setzt die nato und
kontrolliert mit aspiration die lage das
ist aber nach empfehlungen des robert
koch instituts und auch nach
empfehlungen des österreichischen
nationalen ins gremiums bei den üblichen
stellen also in der regel im schulter-
muskel nicht notwendig weil im bereich
dieser körperstellen zb der schulter
muskel
verlaufen keine gefäße keine nerven
strenge die groß genug sind und es ist
so ja nicht daher nicht möglich dass es
eine injektion in die in das gefäß
passiert und es gibt weder berichte noch
verletzungen
noch einen zusammenhang zu head wegen
gerinnungsstörungen bei dieser
abrechnungsmethode
ich verlasse mich da sehr auf das
personal in den straßen aber auch in den
ordinationen die nach empfehlungen
meines ressorts die impfungen korrekt
verbrechen
gerade dieses gesundheitspersonal hat in
der pandemie wirklich übermenschliches
geleistet und verdient es nicht durch
solche verunsicherungen hier
belangt zu werden
die kogit 19 schimpfen ist sicher wir
brauchen eine hohe durchimpfungsrate
um die verbreitung des virus einzudämmen
die behauptung von verletzungen durch
impfungen und bei impfungen
dient er dazu gezielte bevölkerung zu
verunsichern und auch in weiterer folge
hier die gesellschaft zu spalten
wir brauchen aber gerade in dieser
ausnahmesituation der pandemie
zusammenhalt und einen eine
rückbesinnung auf wissenschaftliche
empfehlungen die verbreitung von fake
news ist absolut gefährlich ich
appelliere an jede bürgerin und jeden
bürger
zuverlässige quellen zu konsultieren und
in fluten zu hinterfragen
[Applaus]
nun ist die redezeit fünf minuten
sehr geehrter präsident verkehrminister
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
geschätzte damen und herren die jugend
österreichs hat ein jugendwort 2021
gewählt und da ist das wort krise
herausgekommen cr ing das heißt
übersetzt was wie peinlich und
fremdschämen und wissen sie was mir
gleich in den sinn kommt wenn ich dieses
wort krise das ist nämlich das wort das
mir sofort in den sinn kommt wenn ich an
die beiträge der fpö pandemie bekämpfung
denke
und ich bin auch etwas verwundert bei
dieser kurz debatte der abgeordnete wo
mode beantragen eine kurze debatte zu
folgenden themen ist das vor verzicht
auf aspiration bei intramuskuläre
injektion hinsichtlich den empfehlungen
des rk ii
was hat eine fach medizinische
diskussion mit einer kurze party zu tun
gar nix aber mich wundert es auch nicht
ich diskutiere gern mit den kollegen
wurm ich würde ihm aber vorschlagen also
kaum nicht in wien und erklären dann was
aspiration bedeutet ja oder nein dann
hätten wir zwei fliegen auf einen schlag
ich beschäftige mich lieber in diesen
paar minuten mit dingen die mich
wirklich interessieren noch beschäftigen
und nicht mit dingen die bei der
kursdebatte nichts verloren haben zum
beispiel die menschenrechte es gibt
menschenrechte auf vieles wir hören dass
immer wieder es gibt ein menschenrecht
auf hochgradigen unsinn zu glauben und
diesen unsinn auch öffentlich
herauszubringen aber es gibt kein
menschenrecht ich darauf anderen
menschen
lebensgefährliche therapien zu empfehlen
oder
ungeimpft andere menschen dringend
benötigte krankenhausbetten weg zu
nehmen weil man nicht in der lage ist
das konzept in funk zu verstehen in form
ist training für das immunsystem
manche harte impfgegner manchen harten
gegnern ist jedes mittel recht
halbwahrheiten erfindungen
übertreibungen und es gibt einen spruch
die haben wir auch immer wieder in den
sinn kommt verleumdung verträge nur drei
ist es bleibt immer etwas hängen
die pandemie zwingt uns lieb gewonnene
gewissheiten über bord zu werfen das
ändert sich schnell viel zu schnell für
unsere selbst für logan und
epidemiologen die wirklichen experten
lernen stehen die stationen die dinge
sind ständig im fluss und das verlangt
uns viel ab und sorgt dafür ängste und
ich habe wirklich viel viel verständnis
dafür für die ängste der menschen aber
ich wiederhole immer was bewirkt denn
eine impfung und warum wir sind wir so
dafür es geht darum die krankheitslast
in der bevölkerung langfristig zu
vermeiden damit wir nicht dauernd von
loch zu loch dann stolpern und es sollen
schwere verläufe von komik und auch
todesfälle vermieden werden wir haben
mittlerweile 14.000 kothe und das ist
sehr traurig
beste mittel gegen diese pläne sind die
wissenschaft die eigenverantwortung und
auf der hausverstand und alle drei
dürfen und müssen verwendet werden aber
in der öffentlichen debatte
werden der hausverstand und die
wissenschaft wie konkurrenten
dargestellt dabei sind sie einfach nicht
vergleichbar was ist der hausverstand
erlauben sie mir kurz ist zu erläutern
das ist gerade das wissen von
generationen zu generationen weitergeben
ist in vielen bereichen von bedeutung
und wenn ich schnell entscheiden muss
kann ich nichts anders machen aber in
einem über jahre dauernden pandemie kann
ich mit einem hausverstand nicht viel
lösen und was ist dann die
wissenschaftliche logik das geht von
thesen und überprüfungen aus führen sie
gut zu ist ein stetiger prozess der sich
verändert und damit widerspruch erzeugt
und die wissenschaft impliziert immer
neue erkenntnisse
wenn sich das virus ändert ändert sich
auch die rahmenbedingungen
und man muss klar sagen die wissenschaft
die frage nach den naturgesetzen ist und
mit dem verständnis der zusammenhänge
es ergeben sich dann oft widersprüche
aber die wissenschaft liegt nicht dass
es oft nicht einfach sehr kompliziert
und mühsam aber dieses bemühen erwarte
ich mir von vielen und vor allem von
abgeordneten in diesem haus eine studie
von april 20 20 herauszupicken und einen
satz daraus zu zitieren hilft uns heute
im juni 2002 im jänner 2022 nicht weiter
die frage die sich heute und auch nach
der pandemie stellt wie erreicht man den
leuten die den glauben an die
wissenschaft verloren haben und das
zauberwort für mich und für so viele
heißt bildung man muss in der schule
damit anfangen nochmals die impfung
gegen kit ist und bleibt die einzige
mögliche breit anwendbare möglichkeit
die krankheitslast und auch die
krankenhaus last zu vermindern und zu
reduzieren es gibt ganz klare evidenzen
das ganz besonders personen davon
profitieren die bereits die dritte
impfung erhalten haben und es gibt auch
weiter eine durchgemachte erkrankung
birgt weitere listen als die impfung
also bitte in pfungstadt schimpfen oder
umkämpften danke
sabine cook
vielen dank herr präsident geschätzte
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich bin ein bisschen positiver kollege
wurde
also danke dass du dich dem thema in
tuningen positiven erst man merkt dass
die daten eine gewisse wirkung entfalten
und du zunehmend auch von der
wirksamkeit der impfungen überzeugt ist
und scheinbar hast du jetzt sich diesen
thema zunehmend auch kritisch genähert
und der zweifel einzige dennoch bleibt
nach seinen recherchen ist jetzt ob die
ärztinnen und ärzte wohl das richtig
machen ob die das wort können und ob ich
da irgendwie unsicher weil im internet
recherchiert und draufkommen bist doch
seine forum diskutiert worden ist jetzt
dazu vielleicht nur zwei andere jungen
mann könnte das auf kurzem wege auch mit
dem hausarzt klären wäre eine variante
die zweite frage ist natürlich um alles
das was uns interessiert über den weg
einer parlamentarischen anfrage hier im
parlament auch diskutieren muss lothar
bis 100 minister auskunft geben muss
nicht immer so zum uneingeschränkt seine
meinung aber es sollte ja eigentlich um
andere dinge kümmern so geht es
natürlich nicht dass man jede frage die
ihm auftaucht im internet und gleichen
wie als anfrage einbringen weil das
nächste show am morgen im fernsehen dann
kriegst will mann und frau kann die frau
bundesministerin dana warum haben wir in
österreich keine u boote also so geht's
halt nicht es gibt schon dinge die man
durchaus auch selber recherchieren
könnte
ich will positiv formulieren wenn es
wirklich interesse da ist es gut dann
kann man darüber reden nächster versuch
einer panikmache ist dann ist das
natürlich nicht gewerbe das tut man
nicht zu erzählen dass die ärztinnen und
ärzte wissen wie man impft das muss
nicht sein und die märkte darauf
eingehen wie man einfach sich die mühe
gemacht hätte und kurz auch gegoogelt
hätte da gibt es zum beispiel die
erklärung auch dass tico in deutschland
basierend auf den empfehlungen des
robert-koch-institutes und die schreiben
dann warum hat die stiko empfohlen auf
eine aspiration bei der injektion von
impfstoffen zu verzichten genau das ist
es was dich interessiert findet haben
was ein gibt im internet dass horst die
schwere der es ist klar es braucht nur
auf google man eingeben innerhalb von 30
sekunden ist alles beantwortet da muss
man nicht an fragen einbringen da muss
man nicht ewig diskutieren als es geht
relativ rasch und kurz zusammengefasst
war fotos internet dazu und die stiko in
deutschland es geht darum dass das ganze
schmerzfrei funktioniert und sorgt dort
dürft international durchaus auch
menschen gegeben haben die sich damit
beschäftigen und die schau traum kommen
die impfungen noch besser machen
schmerzfreie zb und wie kann man das
ganze evidenzbasiert weiterentwickeln
und die sind draufkommen dass die
blutgefäße an den körperstellen die
fliegen diktion von impfstoffen in polen
sind und in reichweite der nadel liegen
diesen zu klein um eine versehentliche
intravenöse gabe zu ermöglichen berichte
über verletzungen von patienten aufgrund
unterlassener aspiration die gibt es
nicht also danke nochmal für einen
versuch wenn man es positiv formulieren
freut mich seine entwicklungskurve vom
im kritik hat mich beförderte jetzt nur
noch angst vor spritzen das ging auch
noch miteinander hin aber danke für die
spannende debatte
[Applaus]
danke herr bundesminister kollege gucke
ich hoffe dass die rede sein ansinnen
dass man jetzt parlamentarische anfragen
durch google suchen ersetzen das
mediendorf schaden ist der entstandene
spd als ich hoffe dass du das nicht
ernst gemeint hast was du jetzt gesagt
hat die kollegin lager hat vorher auch
interessante dinge von sich gegeben und
hat geschrieben ausgesprochen davon dass
also die impfung der siegeszug der
wissenschaft gegen das virus gewesen ist
die kollegin maria schon wieder niemand
mehr im raum zumindest sehe ich sie
nicht aber ich glaube eher dass es da
ich glaube eher dass es ein raubzug der
pharmakonzerne gegen den geldbeutel
steuerzahler und deren grund reiter und
grundrechte sehr geehrte damen und
herren das ist aus der heute mit
diskutieren
möchten doch ganz kurz eingehen auch auf
die anfrage vom bundesminister die immer
ungenügend beantwortet sind unser für
die anfragebeantwortung es debatten kann
man keine türen in dem haus das man da
irgendwie auf einen nenner konto möchte
schon noch etwas zurückkommen aus der
bundesminister heute auch im
hauptausschuss in der früh gesagt hat
und ich würde sagen der bundesminister
sich mittlerweile schon opfer der
eigenen
propaganda geworden und zwar obwohl
clijsters die infoniqa einfach nicht so
gut wie nicht mehr greift von sie uns
jetzt eine impfpflicht verordnen sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
bundesregierung in anderen ländern hat
man schon verstanden dass das nicht die
lösung ist warum das bei uns noch immer
so hoch gehalten wird sie sprechen von
der wichtigkeit der immunisierung gegen
omikron uns bringen und führen die
impfungen treffen wie gesagt es gibt
studien die mittlerweile das gegenteil
behaupten dass die immunisierung monika
umgang mit ihnen mit der impfung nicht
gelingen und wenn es war das nicht
glauben und wenn sie sagen ich bin
schwul blatt dann rede ich mit herrn
bundeskanzler der nicht zuletzt vor
wenigen tagen selbst ein unikum
erkrankte sowohl vorträge hilft ist und
vielleicht sogar inter nacht leuchtet
sehr geteilt ist sehr geehrte damen und
herren und das ist der grund warum wir
diese debatte führen und das ist der
grund warum wir freiheitliche sagen man
kann diese nicht funktionierende waffen
diese nicht funktionierende waffen und
der zertrümmerung auf grund und
freiheitsrechte den menschen in diesem
land verordnen das geht so nicht und
dafür stehen die freiheitliche erhält
und eines haben sie noch nicht
beantwortet heute es kommen jetzt noch
900.000 personen dazu die entweder
chinesen sind oder zweimal geimpft sind
die mit ersten februar dann auch von
ihnen zu bürgern zweiter klasse erklärt
werden ich bin gespannt ist das erklären
wolle und wie sie das rechtfertigen
wollen dass auch diese menschen die
gesund sind auf wesentliche bürgerrechte
recht in zukunft verzichten werden
müssen der bundesminister das geht sich
alles hinten und vorn nicht aus und die
unsinnigkeit der maßnahme die möchte ich
ihnen einfach nur an einer an einem
beispiel erklären und so an dem beispiel
der sperrstunde in der gastronomie sind
wir heute davon gesprochen dass sie die
sperrstunde beibehalten wohl und sie
haben auch gesagt die nacht und schnee
gastronomie ich weiß nichts was das
genau sein soll ich hoffe dass die
lokale vom herrn hohen osternacht und
schnee lokale geht sondern ich meine
sind nehmen die lokale in aussicht die
am abend hochform aber warum schließen
sie diese lokale das ist nicht
nachvollziehbar zu haben ich habe es
vorher gerade erklärt bereits einen
großen teil der österreichischen
bevölkerung ohne ihn zu bürgern zweiter
klasse gemacht sie haben diese bürger
eingesperrt die dürfen ja gar nicht mehr
in dieser zeit gehen und ihnen das
gaststätten also warum halten sie
trotzdem an dieser 10 uhr sperrstunde
fest herr bundesminister klavier ihre
argumentation geht sich hinten und vorne
nicht aus
und noch ein punkt und ich glaube das
sollte man auch den internationalen
vergleich nicht scheuen wenn eine
mannschaft welche länder bis jetzt den
pflicht eingeführt haben dann fehlt mir
da der vatikan auffallen
ecuador auf und dann fehlt mir der
tschekisten wenn man schaut über welche
demokratische systeme diese länder
verfügen ja dann möchte ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht dass österreich in dieser
reihe stehen und auch das ist ja etwas
draussen wo man der außenwirkung einmal
betrachten muss wo man wissen muss wo
man da überhaupt dazu gehören möchte und
wo man hier wirklich adäquat ich sage
nein sehr geehrte damen und herren das
einzige womit sich diese bundesregierung
auszeichnet und übrigens respekt von
demonstranten die hier im josefs platz
draußen stehen und ihr gesicht zeigen
ihre komfortzone verlassen um ihnen zu
sagen damit dass sie am holzweg unter
wir unterwegs sind aber das einzige
womit sich diese bundesregierung
auszeichnet ist ihre herzlosigkeit und
ich möchte noch ein beispiel bringen das
mit gestern sehr berührt hat uns das
beispiel eines mannes weit über 80 der
gestern vor dem krankenhaus in baden
angetroffen worden ist in vollkommener
verzweiflung dieser er ist eigentlich
gegen seine überzeugung drei mal
hingegangen um seine kranke frau im
krankenhaus besuchen zu können wenn sie
regelmäßig dort ist er hat sich gestern
auch für den besuch im ganzen haus baden
noch einen pcr test machen lassen und
ist von dort abgewiesen worden sehr
geehrte damen und herren dieser alte
mann ist dort abgewiesen worden er
konnte seine schwer kranke frau nicht
besuchen warum weil die landeskliniken
holding holding in niederösterreich
festgelegt hat dass es ab jetzt sofort
also ab sofort nur mehr
besuchsmöglichkeiten geben wird einmal
in der woche eine halbe stunde meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren das ist
die art und weise wie sie mit der aufbau
generation umgehen das ist die art und
weise wie sie mit menschen umgehen das
ist die art und weise wie sie auf der
psyche dieser menschen herumtrampeln und
ich sage ihnen eines von diesem
rednerpult aus dafür können sie sich
alle und alle die da heute mitmachen in
grund und boden schämen
[Applaus]
danke herr präsident wir haben uns in
der präsidiale sitzung darauf
verständigt dass wir abwesenheiten von
abgeordneten heute nicht kommentieren
sie haben selber eingangs der sitzung
darauf hingewiesen dass wir aufgrund der
omicron variante unter seine hütten
infektionsgeschehen und risikos hier
heute auch aufgelockert sitzen der herr
abgeordnete hafenecker hat jetzt in
seiner rede darauf hingewiesen dass
unsere gruppe pro7 aber nicht am platz
sei ich erwarte mir von der fpö oder sie
sich an abmachungen die wir im rahmen
oder präsidial sitzung auch treffen sich
auch daran hält
zu wort gemeldet ist
krank der präsident sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
ministerin ein minister sehr geehrte
minister auf der anderen seite schon zu
sagen
ich habe heute schon den ganzen tag
seitdem dieses verlangen auf meinem
tisch liegt eine ganze zeit gedacht wie
sie sind dazu gekommen und in der
zwischenzeit ist mir glaube ich da ein
großes licht aufgegangen
die tage ist die fpö zusammengesessen
oder unüberlegt und hat sich gedacht
hast du nur damit man ja möglichst auch
den kollegen beim reden lassen können
und die kollegen half wenig leute reden
lassen können was soll man machen wenn
wir da jetzt noch tun da haben wir ja
vor kurzem eine beantwortung aus dem
ministerium hereinbekommen doch einfach
so als ob diese als ob diese anfragen
aber beantwortet wäre und stellen wir
eben ein verlangen das wird meine
anfrage besprechung machen und wie komme
ich auf diese idee der kollege vom
stellt sich hier heraus und redet über
alles mögliche aber er redet nicht über
die von ihm gestellte anfrage er redet
nicht darüber über dieses verlangen
sondern er redet eben über die
sicherheit oder eben über die mögliche
unsicherheit
aktuellen kopien von aber okay
schauen wir uns heute mal eben auch
anfassen der kollege wurden wir da
gemacht hat er behauptet die ode oder
erstellt so bis in den raum die kopien
von die wirkt nicht ist unsicher da gibt
es nebenwirkungen jahr stimmt bei jeder
impfung kann es nebenwirkungen gegeben
hat auch nie jemand bestritten aber was
sind die fakten und über die sind mir
reden wir haben im vergangenen jahr
circa 16 4 millionen impfdosen in
österreich verhilft wir haben aktuell
mit jahreswechsel 367 anträge nach dem
im schadens gesetz in österreich
vorliegenden anträge bitteschön das
heißt nicht dass diese das diesen
stattgegeben wurde und dass da eben
sozusagen beschieden wurde das eben hier
wirklich in schäden vorliegen sondern
367 anträge nach dem schadens gesetz zu
16 4 millionen impfdosen oder wie der
professor dr kollaritsch gesagt hat naja
ein antrag pro 50.000 impfungen das ist
fakt das hat nichts damit zu tun dass
wir eine schlechte impfung hätten oder
eine gefährliche impfung hätten sondern
eine auf 50.000 setzen wir das bitte in
die relation und das sind anträge das
sind nicht beschieden impfschäden und
das wird man schon auch verändern aus
meiner sicht also das was der kollege
wurm hier heraußen gemacht hat ist so
wie es heute eigentlich üblich ist bei
der fpö sich hinaus zu stellen es hat
bis also zu tun hat da haben wir was
gehört dort gibt es vielleicht einen
einzelfall dort vielleicht
aussehen der studie sehr sehr selektiv
heraus zu zitieren falsch infos auch
durchaus zu zu verbreiten was meine ich
damit nur die kolleginnen belakowitsch
die sich im märz 2021 herausgestellt hat
und über von über 2.000 impfstoffen in
ganz europa fabuliert hat die er in der
zwischenzeit in den statistiken
aufscheinen das hat sich bis heute nicht
herausgestellt dass es diese damals
gegeben hätte aber genau das ist doch
die politik der fpö in diesem
zusammenhang wenn es im cockpit geht
immer so bist du da bist oder sich
herauszustellen und zu sagen na ja bis
delta war klar dass die impfung das
risiko senkt moment aber lieber kollege
bestellter war wirklich körpers das dass
die impfung das risiko senkt nämlich mit
einer effektivität von 95 prozent
festgestellt durch die jahres und wir
haben in der zwischenzeit ja auch
labordaten und es wird immer
angezweifelt von den kolleginnen und
kollegen der fpö das eben auch die
impfung nach der musterung wieder einer
effektivität von 70 bis 75 prozent gegen
schwere verläufe bei omikron neben hilft
genauso wie macht gegen intensiv
pflichtige verläufe also dass alles so
immer dass es wird immer ein bisserl
dann auf die seite geschoben geschoben
von den kolleginnen und kollegen und
weil sie das leben hier heute wieder
machen wollten haben sie hat dann dieses
verlangen gestellt wo sie über gott und
die welt reden aber nicht über das und
dass es in ihrem verlangen hier geht es
ist sehr durchschaubar was sie machen
das ist im endeffekt immer das übliche
politische kleingeld schlagen das eben
die kolleginnen und kollegen der fpö
oder betreiben wollen sie sehen sich
heute eben im aufwind aber ganz ehrlich
gesagt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das ist kein konstruktiver beitrag dazu
eine pandemie zu meistern das ist kein
konstruktiver beitrag
menschenleben zu sichern dafür zu sorgen
dass in diesem land wieder normalität
einkehrt und das wäre eigentlich dorthin
soll das konstruktive opposition hier
sein könnte glaubt im gegensatz zu den
kolleginnen und kollegen von der sp und
von dem aus die ihren auftrag durchaus
konstruktiv angehen
zu wort
gemeldet freu mich
danke herr präsident geschätzte
mitglieder der bundesregierung möchte
für die fernsehzuschauer noch mal in
erinnerung rufen dass diese kurze
debatte die vorherige debatte
unterbricht und obwohl man hier das
vermischt haben ich jetzt nicht um die
impfpflicht geht sondern eigentlich um
eine anfrage der fpö zur frage wie die
impf wird ich bin auch nicht ganz sicher
ob die antwort fachlich überall richtig
verstanden wurde dass die freiheitlichen
heute aufführen ist ein
inszenierter tanz und das nützt
niemandem außer vielleicht den
umfragedaten der freiheitlichen partei
und jetzt kann man über
die möglichkeiten wie wir aus der
pandemie herauskommen geteilt der
meinung sein aber das was hier gespielt
wird ist nicht schön wenn sich der
körper partikel herausstellten wie das
rumpelstilzchen sagt ich nehme meine
impfung nicht nein meinen vom nehme ich
nicht ja das ist halt ein bisschen
wenig erwachsener mal vorsichtig gesagt
und mit um mit dieser anfrage mit der
versuchte unsicherheit zu schüren nicht
immer mit den ängsten der menschen zu
spielen die sich sorgen machen vor der
impfung es sind in österreich mehr als
17 millionen kubik impfungen verabreicht
worden so und dann ziehen sie fälle
heraus und entwickeln die zahlen in ein
verhältnis setzen 17 millionen impfungen
und hat in der früh im hauptausschuss
hat die kollegin fürst die
herzmuskelentzündungen herausgezogen es
gibt
186 fälle bei denen die vermutung
besteht es könnte einen zusammenhang
geben mit der impfung aber das heißt
nicht dass tatsächlich ein zusammenhang
besteht sondern es gibt die vermutung
aber das heißt auf eine von
hunderttausend instrument gibt es
nachher eine solche vermutung wissen sie
und damit spielen sie mit diesen ängsten
und mit den ressentiments spiel
und natürlich eine ein wesentlicher
beitrag dazu dass sie überhaupt spielen
können mit ressentiments ist die
grottenschlechte datenlage in unserer
republik und das ist unter minister
möglich ein so schlechtes untermann
schober und in den 70 jahren davor war
weil das gesundheitsministerium weileder
70 jahre wurst und es hat sich keiner
darum gekümmert und wir wenn wieder eine
pandemie kommt sind wir gleich schlecht
vorbereitet wie auf diese das ist
natürlich die verantwortung die sie
haben wir wissen immer noch keine
exakten zahlen zu spitalsbetten wir das
ams bricht immer wieder zusammen dass
contact racing funktioniert nicht wir
wissen immer noch nicht welche
vorerkrankungen die menschen haben damit
kommt ins spital kommen dass die
datenlage so schlecht ist verantworten
sie und sie ermöglichen diesen leuten
dass sie mit den schlechten daten und
den ängsten der menschen spielen
und
dann hat der kollege hafenecker noch
darauf hingewiesen wie viel geld
anscheinend ausgegeben werde für sin ja
also wer immer vorne dabei war laut zu
schreien dass die tests gratis sein
müssen weil die freiheitliche partei und
wir geben viermal so viel aus fürs
testen wie fürs impfen das hat uns aber
in der pandemie gar nichts gebracht wir
haben wir testen zehnmal so viel wie die
deutschen und haben genau den gleichen
pandemie verlauf diese massen testerei
von symptomen losen hat uns nicht
verankert haben viele leute goldene nase
verdient auch genug apotheker die zu
ihrer wählerschaft gehört im gehirn
haben gute goldene nase verdient aber
mit dem impfen für sie schon wie ein
viertel davon ausgegeben und was kostet
ein tag auf der intensivstation
jetzt können wir über die wirkung der
impfung streiten es wäre uns allen
lieber die wirkung wäre noch besser als
sie ist aber intensiv aufenthalte
verhindert sie nachweislich und ein tag
auf der intensivstation kostet
mindestens 3000 euro ein tag und wenn da
einer wegen kurven auf intensiv fliegt
dann legen wir die leute zwei drei
wochen dort da wird ein vermögen
ausgegeben für die behandlung dieser
menschen diese die die impfung
verweigert haben weil sie mit ihren
ängsten gespielt haben
und was für ein spiel das ist sieht man
ja auch wenn man sich die freiheit
liefert ein bisschen genauer anschauen
leute wie herr müller senior wird die
genres passe und wie die frühere
gesundheitsministerin hartinger klein
oder frühere gesundheitsstaatssekretär
panik die genieren sich ja für ihre
partei sie entschuldigen sich öffentlich
für die linie des herbert kickl und wenn
sie
wenn sie in den wiener landtags klub der
freiheitlichen schauen dann ist die
einzige ungeimpfte person dort der
überläufer aus der vp und alle anderen
sind
also kann ich nur sagen
besinnen sie sich fragen was bei ich
habe auch nicht immer die gleiche
meinung wie der minister ganz oft eine
andere aber man sollte nicht mit den
ängsten der menschen spielen
sofort ist niemand mehr gemeldet die
partie beendet ich nehme die
verhandlungen zu den
tagesordnungspunkten 6 bis 8 wieder auf
und so weit ist gewaltig verhoben die
wagen bitte sehr bei erste das wort
verfahren
wir haben vielen dank herr präsident
sehr geehrte bundesregierung für
bundesminister und sehr geehrte damen
und herren es geht heute hier um eine
sensible aber eine wichtige entscheidung
es geht um die frage ob die korona
schutzimpfung für alle in österreich ab
18 jahren verpflichtend sein soll oder
nicht und wir müssen uns heute dieser
frage stellen weil
und da kann ich die bundesregierung aus
ihrer verantwortung nicht entlassen weil
vieles in den letzten zwei jahren falsch
gelaufen ist weil viele es verabsäumt
wurde die impfrate ist leider noch immer
viel zu niedrig und es ist nicht
gelungen genug menschen zum impfen zu
bewegen genug menschen um künftig eine
überlastung der spitäler bei künftigen
corona wählen und damit weitere lockt
als nachhaltig und dauerhaft zu
verhindern das ist ein problem und hier
sind wir schon bei einem entscheidenden
punkt
die verpflichtende schutzimpfung gegen
korona die wir uns alle nicht gewünscht
haben ist leider notwendig geworden um
diese im pflücke die es noch immer gibt
in österreich zu schließen denn nur dann
und davon bin ich überzeugt haben wir
eine chance haben wir eine realistische
chance auf ein leben wie wir es vor
corinna gekannt haben was meine ich
das meine ich damit was ist dein leben
wie wir es vor corinna gekannt habe wie
definieren wir das in erster linie
ich denke mir das so
dass jeder mensch in österreich die
sicherheit hat wenn er oder sie
medizinische versorgung braucht er diese
versorgung auch bekommt eine garantie
dafür bestens medizinisch versorgt zu
sein wenn die spitäler aber überlastet
sind so wie es in den letzten zwei
jahren leider immer wieder der fall war
dann ist genau diese sicherheit in
österreich gefährdet und je mehr
menschen wegen corona ins spital müssen
je mehr auf intensivstationen behandelt
werden müssen desto mehr ressourcen
fehlen natürlich in der behandlung
anderer patientinnen und patienten
herzinfarkte schlaganfälle
unfallopfer onkologische patientinnen
und patienten es ist unbestritten sehr
geehrte damen und herren und auch obwohl
heute gerade von ihnen von seiten der
fpö immer wieder das gegenteil behauptet
wird und wurde die impfung rettet leben
die impfung rettet leben das eigene und
das leben anderer es sterben noch immer
viel zu viele menschen an corona sie
sterben zum einen an den direkten folgen
von kowitz sie sterben aber auch an den
indirekten folgen der pandemie weil ihre
operationstermine einfach verschoben
werden monatelang verschoben werden oder
erkrankungen man es
vorsorgeuntersuchungen zu spät oder
sagen wir mal sehr spät erkannt und
diagnostiziert werden auch das wird in
den kommenden jahren noch sehr viel
kommende jahr zu früher todesopfer
fordern es sterben auch zu viele
menschen an den indirekten folgen weil
akute herzinfarkt und ich habe schon
gesagt schlaganfälle und dergleichen
nicht rechtzeitig intensivmedizinisch
versorgt werden können und das darf
niemals hingenommen werden sehr geehrte
damen und herren
der schutz der gesundheit der schutz von
leben muss immer an oberster stelle
stehen und bei der impfung geht es also
darum nicht nur sich sondern auch andere
zu schützen
vor allem geht es darum diejenigen zu
schützen die sich selbst nicht durch
diese impfung schützen können und das
sind bis zu zehn prozent in der
bevölkerung
die chance auf ein annähernd normales
leben wie wir es vorher kannten heißt
aber auch keine freiheitsbeschränkungen
mehr
freiheitsbeschränkungen an die wir uns
leider gewöhnen mussten die letzten zwei
jahre ausgangs beschränkungen kontakt
reduktionen quasi ein herunterfahren des
sozialen des wirtschaftlichen lebens in
österreich massive eingriffe in unsere
persönlichen verhalten die dadurch
gegeben waren mit verheerenden
psychischen folgen mit verheerenden
sozialen aber auch wirtschaftlichen
folgen für die menschen für die
gesellschaft für unser land und das
diesen permanenten
teufelskreislauf das auf und es zu
diesen teufelskreislauf der
unsicherheiten gibt es aus meiner sicht
und aus sicht der meisten expertinnen
und experten einen effektiven weg heraus
und das ist die hohe durchimpfungsrate
in österreich die schutzimpfung
die schützen von gm corona verpflichtend
zu machen
ist nun ein notausgang es ist der
notausgang in richtung
oder sagen wir einen notausgang weg und
raus aus den ständigen einschränkungen
und beschränkungen unserer persönlichen
grund und freiheitsrechte so wie wir das
die letzten zwei jahren erdulden mussten
ja sehr geehrte damen und herren in den
vergangenen zwei wochen vergangenen
wochen insgesamt
wurden leider auch viele unwahrheiten
verbreitet diskutiert und behauptet fakt
ist vielmehr diese impfung schützt sie
schützt auch gegen omikron diese impfung
schützt vor schweren verläufen
jede impfung zählt und deswegen haben
wir auch keine zeit zu verlieren es geht
ums tempo es geht um die zeit
und es geht aber nicht nur um omikron
das greift viel zu kurz denn wir wissen
nicht welche mutationen welche
virusvariante nach omikron kommen wird
und das ist entscheidend ist sie so
infektiös wie delta aber so ansteckend
wie omikron kann sein wir wissen es
nicht ist tomic runter anfang vom ende
der pandemie oder anfang der ende mai
kann sein wir wissen es nicht und so
lange wir es nicht wissen sehr geehrte
damen und herren ist es unsere
verantwortung den weg dass sicherheit zu
gehen und ist es unsere verantwortung
auf nummer sicher zu gehen zum schutz
der gesundheit der menschen in
österreich
sehr geehrte damen und herren niemand
niemand hat sich die heutige
entscheidung zu dieser abstimmung leicht
gemacht wir sozialdemokratinnen und
sozialdemokraten übernehmen
verantwortung
verantwortung für den schutz des lebens
verantwortung für den schutz der
gesundheit der bevölkerung
in regierungszeiten genauso wie in den
zeiten der opposition
und eines ist dabei und für uns ganz
zentral impfen ist ein solidarischer akt
in wien ist ein solidarischer akt mit
dem man nicht nur sich selbst schützt
sondern vor allem auch andere die
schwächeren die sich selbst nicht
schützen können die kinder die noch
nicht geimpft werden können das
gesundheitspersonal das am rande und am
limit seiner kräfte ist nach zwei jahren
pandemie und einen punkt möchte ich da
auch noch herausstreichen nämlich einen
der für uns auch wichtig ist dieses
gesetz darf keinen tag länger gelten als
notwendig sehr geehrte damen und herren
und genau das
und genau das ist jetzt in diesem
gesetzentwurf verankert
verankert deshalb weil es laufend auf
verfassungsmäßigkeit und rechtmäßigkeit
überprüft wird durch expertinnen und
experten und in folge auch diesem hohen
haus bericht zu erstatten ist darüber ob
diese verfassungsmäßigkeit überhaupt
noch gegeben ist das ist notwendig weil
sich die rahmenbedingungen des virus die
pandemie ständig verändern das wissen
wir das haben wir gelernt und deswegen
ist das ein ganz entscheidender punkt in
diesem vorliegenden gesetz und eines war
mir und war uns von anfang an in dieser
impf debatte immer sehr wichtig nämlich
dass es ergänzend zu einer verpflichtung
auch positive anreize gibt die die
menschen positiv motivieren sich
zusätzlich impfen zu lassen
zusätzlich zur impfung positive signale
aus schicken das ist ein ganz wichtiges
zeichen gerade in zeiten dieser
gesellschaftlichen spaltung in
österreich und es ist gleichzeitig eine
win win situation durch
kaufkraftstärkung von imf gutscheinen
von imf prämien wird die heimische
wirtschaft unterstützt und arbeitsplätze
in dieser zeit gesichert und geschaffen
sehr geehrte damen und herren
verantwortung heißt aber auch
nicht mit den ängsten und sorgen der
menschen in österreich zu spielen
sehr geehrte damen und herren
wenn wissenschaftliche fakten
systematisch geleugnet werden wenn
verschwörungstheorien
verbreitet werden wenn das medizinische
personal
bedroht und angefeindet wird in
österreich wenn kinder wie wir heute
lesen mussten weil sie masken tragen von
corona leugnern bedroht beschimpft und
angeschrien werden dann dann muss es
widerspruch geben und von allen
demokratischen kräften dieses landes
eines kann ich ihnen an dieser stelle
versichern die sozialdemokratie wird
diese verantwortung zu jedem zeitpunkt
übernehmen wir haben das in der
vergangenheit getan und wir werden das
auch in zukunft tun vielen dank
zu wort gemeldet bundesminister mit
steinen
sehr geehrter herr präsident hätte damen
und herren abgeordnete
der damen und herren zu hause heute ist
ein wichtiger tag
heute wollen wir gemeinsam einen
essenziellen schritt in der
österreichischen roma politik gehen wir
haben hier eine vorausschauende maßnahme
die einen am tisch liegt eine
vorausschauende maßnahme wie wir sie in
den letzten zwei jahren pandemie
bekämpfung noch nicht hatten mit dem
vorliegenden gesetzesentwurf zur
impfpflicht haben wir einen großen und
erstmals auch einen besonders
nachhaltigen hebel im kampf gegen die
pandemie in unseren händen diese
maßnahme wird uns helfen zwar nicht
gleich morgen und gegen unikum
aber das war auch gar nicht das ziel
dieses gesetzes
filme wird diese impfpflicht uns für die
nächsten wählen nützen im kampf gegen
bevorstehende virusvarianten so können
wir schaffen den kreislauf aus offen zu
sperren auswählen und lockt tanz zu
entkommen und daher
und daher braucht es dieses gesetz jetzt
so dringend
wir reagieren damit nicht einfach
sondern wir setzen vorausschauend und
aktiv einen wichtigen schritt für
zukünftige entwicklungen nicht nur
deswegen bin ich stolz auf diesen
gesetzentwurf sondern auch vor allen
wegen seiner entstehung vier
parlamentsparteien haben gemeinsam mit
vertreterinnen und vertretern aus der
zivilgesellschaft und viele expertinnen
und experten daran gearbeitet
dieses gesetz steht trotz dieser heiklen
materie auf einem breiten fundament auf
einem so breiten fundament wie kaum eine
andere regelung
der wiese suchen wieder herunterzunehmen
dankeschön
nachdem wir uns ende vergangenen jahres
darauf geeinigt haben diesen gemeinsamen
schritt zu gehen hat es zahlreiche
runden gegeben wir haben mit
medizinerinnen und medizinern gesprochen
wir haben mit
epidemiologen gesprochen die täterinnen
und tätern wir haben mit vertreterinnen
und vertretern der
glaubensgemeinschaften gesprochen mit
pensionisten vertreterinnen mit jugend
vertreterinnen wir haben viel diskutiert
und auch durchaus kontroverse
nicht nur in diesen runden wurde in den
vergangenen wochen viel diskutiert
sondern in ganz österreich und das war
wichtig das war gut denn genau das war
unser ziel
zahlreiche konstruktive stellungnahmen
sind in diesen begutachtungsprozess
thüringer ich bitte nicht in die
unterlagen der mandatare zu
fotografieren von der bühne
entschuldigung
[Applaus]
zahlreiche konstruktive stellungnahmen
sind in diesen begutachtungsprozess
eingegangen viele davon haben auch
eingang gefunden in den gesetzesentwurf
der heute vor ihnen liegt und ich möchte
mich an dieser stelle auch bei
denjenigen bedanken die sich hier
konstruktiv in diesen prozess
eingebracht haben das war viel aufwand
und viel arbeit etwas
möchte ich mich auch ganz explizit den
beteiligten des gehirns bei den news für
die konstruktive zusammenarbeit an
diesem gesetz bedanken
eine stand im zentrum dieses prozesses
im
vordergrund die impfung schützt uns und
dämpfung schützt unsere mitmenschen und
eine hohe durchimpfungsrate schützt
unser gesundheitssystem
die impfpflicht ist eine entscheidung
für uns als gesellschaft
für eine rückkehr zu einem zusammenleben
wie wir vor der pandemie kannten und wie
wir es glaube ich alle recht schmerzlich
vermissen und genau darum geht es bei
der impfpflicht es geht um ein gutes
zusammenleben es geht um das was hinter
der impfpflicht steht um einen
solidaritätsgedanken und ein moment
zusammenhalts prinzip
die impfung rettet nachweislich leben
das müssen wir uns vor augen halten
je mehr menschen einer schutzimpfung
haben desto weniger sterben an den
folgen einer kanone pandemie das ist so
einfach dass
wir
wissen die impfung schützt lassen wir
uns impfen
schützen wir unsere mitmenschen und
schützen wir unser gesundheitssystem
durch eine hohe durchimpfungsrate
und genau deswegen müssen wir uns wie
als gewählte volksvertreter aber auch
wir als gesellschaft alles dafür tun
dass sich so viele menschen wie möglich
in österreich hinten lassen die impfung
insbesondere der booster schützt auch
vor schweren erkrankungen bei der
omicron variante das wissen wir bereits
und deshalb ist eine allgemeine
impfpflicht nach wie vor der richtige
weg
wenn wir aus dem kreislauf des auf und
zusperren und das lockt uns heraus
wollen dann braucht es dieses gesetz und
ein ende der harten maßnahmen zum schutz
vor caron ich glaube das wünschen wir
uns alle
dazu brauchen wir eine gute
gesamtgesellschaftliche immunität im
herbst davon gehen alle expertinnen und
experten aus das vorliegende gesetz wird
uns dabei unterstützen
nun zu den details des
gesetzesentwurfs die gofit 19
impfpflicht wird für alle personen ab
dem 18 geburtstag gelten die ihren
wohnsitz in österreich haben ausgenommen
sind unter anderem schwangere sowie jene
menschen die sich aus eng definierten
medizinischen gründen nicht impfen
lassen können weiters ausgenommen sind
gläserne für einen zeitraum von 180
tagen die kogit 19 impfpflicht wird in
drei phasen anlaufen in der ersten phase
habe anfang februar trittin pflicht in
kraft darüber werden wir auch jeden
haushalt schriftlich informieren diese
phase dauert bis mitte märz
in der zweiten phase ab mitte märz wird
die einhaltung der in pflicht
kontrolliert das wird bei kontrollen der
polizei beispielsweise bei
straßenverkehrs kontrollen erfolgen oder
auch bei der einhaltung der
schutzmaßnahmen für die anwohner
schutzmaßnahmen wer dabei keinen
gültigen
status aufweist wird schriftlich
aufgefordert diesen nachweis nach zu
bringen passiert dies nicht wird eine
strafe von bis zu 600 euro verhängt
in der dritten phase werden wir zunächst
noch einmal alle ungeimpften personen
persönlich per schreiben an ihre pflicht
erinnern und einen monat später wird
dann erneut überprüft wer seine
impfpflicht noch nicht nachgekommen ist
hat man seine hilfe ich dann noch nicht
erfüllt oder auch hier eine strafe von
bis zu 600 euro mir ist auch wichtig zu
betonen dass alle menschen in österreich
die möglichkeit haben diese wichtige
kroner schutzimpfung grades kostenlos zu
erhalten und ich bitte sie als
gesundheitsminister und arzt auch heute
und an dieser stelle bitte nutzen sie
die nächste gelegenheit und lassen sich
auch jetzt schon impfen bitte warten sie
nicht auf die impfpflicht
meine damen und herren die kommen mit 19
pandemie ist noch immer eine besondere
ausnahme situation für uns alle ich bin
aber überzeugt dass mit der impfpflicht
es uns gelingen wird diese so
notwendigen zusätzliche prozente in der
durchimpfungsrate zu erreichen wir haben
uns gemeinsam darauf verständigt dieses
gesetz umzusetzen und das haben wir auch
getan denn gemeinsam können wir so eine
neue und klare perspektive im umgang mit
der pandemie schaffen ein weg zurück zur
normalität die wir uns alle schon so
sehnsüchtig wünschen und genau deshalb
brauchen wir dieses gesetz
daher suche ich sie
werte abgeordnete auch heute um ihre
zustimmung danke
zur gemeinde abgeordnete bitte sehr
danke herr vorsitzender sehr geehrter
herr vizekanzler sehr geehrte mitglieder
der bundesregierung sehr geehrte damen
und herren eine regierung ist immer so
gut wie die berater die sich aussucht
und seitdem experten hearing im
gesundheitsausschuss am vergangenen
montag weiß ich warum diese regierung so
schlecht und warum ihre krone politik so
irrational ist
es war eine frau universitäts-professor
wende horst von der juridischen fakultät
der universität wien geladen von der svp
sie stellt im ausschuss fest es geht
nicht darum ob die impfpflicht im
hinblick auf omikron
verhältnismäßig ist sondern es ist eine
langfristig angelegte maßnahme und so
gedacht das heißt sie wird schon mal
verhältnismäßig werden es sei nur ein
rahmengesetz mit den wesentlichen
punkten wir sollen uns doch nicht
aufregen es kommen ja ändern die
verordnungen des gesundheitsministers
der das dann flexibel und konkret
ausgestaltet der dann die impfstoffe für
uns aussucht und die zeitlichen
intervallen festgelegt sehr beruhigend
sie stellt dann weiter selbst die frage
in den raum was hat diese regierung in
den jahren 2020 und 21 falsch gemacht
hat alles richtig gemacht das ist egal
mit dem hat sie sich gar nicht
beschäftigt es geht nur darum es gibt
jetzt die impfpflicht das ist das
einzige wo sie sich sicher ist dass
verhindert künftige überlastungen des
gesundheitssystems so viel zur
juristischen untermauerung für die
impfpflicht
dann als nächstes
als nächstes kommt die medizinische
experten von den grünen gestellt frau dr
rabatt die niedergelassene ärztin
argumentiert ähnlich
faktenbasiert knallhart fachlich
seriöser im medizinischen bereich ja der
schutzimpfung bei omikron sehr
abgeschwächt man darf aber um mikro noch
nicht verharmlosen es gibt hier sehr
unlustige verläufe es gibt einen kollaps
im gesundheitssystem es sind ganze
abteilungen geschlossen auf die frage
warum nicht wegen corona erkrankungen
des personals etwas sondern aufgrund der
quarantäne regelungen dass aufgrund der
korona politik und der maßnahmen haben
wir hier eine überlastung das war die
antwort lachen sie nur zur frage was ist
eigentlich mit freunden medikamentösen
therapien als alternative zu den
impfungen da gibt es keine ausreichenden
studien zur wirksamkeit zur frage wie
wir es ein bisschen mit kapazitäten
aufbauen personaloffensive zum abfangen
der spitzen im krankenhaus man kann
nicht an allen stellen schrauben und
über die sich für diese frage nicht
kompetent
was sie jedoch sagen kann ist was sie
auch in die relativ belustigt
festgestellt hat die pandemie ist voller
überraschungen es kann immer ganz alles
ganz anders kommen man weiß nicht aber
sie weiß die impfpflicht ist die lösung
für die
einen höhepunkt muss ich noch erwähnen
virologin vergleich gab uns allen
bekannt nicht im ausschuss aber sie ist
ja jeden tag glaube ich in unserem
wohnzimmer hat gestern festgestellt wie
schlecht eine impfung wirkt desto mehr
menschen müssen geimpft sein
bitte lassen sie diese aussage auf sich
wirken wie schlecht eine impfung wirkt
desto mehr menschen müssen geimpft seien
deswegen haben wir die impfpflicht und
das ist die wissenschaft von der sie
immer wieder
und auf der sie direkt ohne politik und
die impfpflicht aufbauend
auf die alles entscheidende frage die
alles entscheidende frage warum zur
vermeidung der regelmäßig drohenden
überlastung des gesundheitssystems die
amtierende regierung seit zwei jahren
kein einziges bett zusätzlich an schafft
sondern entgegen denn betten reduziert
auf normalstation auf intensivstationen
warum keine personalaufstockung
vorgenommen wird sondern im gegenteil
personal reduziert und vertrieben wird
unter anderem durch den imf druck warum
es nicht mehr prämien gibt für das
personal eine personaloffensive konzept
das gesundheitssystem opfern
ökonomischer zu gestalten
sondern nur auf die entrechtung der
bevölkerung gesetzt wird vollkommen
einseitig auf die beantwortung dieser
frage habe ich gewartet die wurde
gemieden wie die pest von den experten
im ausschuss und wie bisher schon von
den politikern und von den medien warum
aber dann müsste man sagen totales
versagen des gesundheitsministers in
organisatorischer politischer hinsicht
und zwei gar nicht gemacht hingekriegt
man kann es nicht glauben aber
natürlich nicht nur versagen des
gesundheitsministers sondern der
bundesregierung die dies nicht ein
fordert von gesundheitsminister
gesundheitsminister mückstein im
ausschuss souverän wie immer hat vor
allen dingen nach dem herunterladen von
den üblichen floskeln festgestellt das
hat er heute nicht wiederholt er ist
sehr stolz auf dieses gesetz er stolz
auf ein gesetz dass hunderttausende
menschen hier in österreich in die ecke
gedrängt in bedrängnis bringt das
gesellschaftlich eine katastrophe es
medizinisch ethisch und rechtlich nicht
zu verantworten ist wird über schlimmste
schicksale drübergefahren auf ein gesetz
des unrechts ist er stolz
er stolz dass so viele mitgehen von der
s-bahn von den news zu apple kann ich
nur sagen die argumentation im ausschuss
sowie heute interessant die regierung
hat versagt
daher impfpflicht für die bevölkerung na
klar ich meine da gehe ich nicht auf die
regierung los sondern lasse ich der
bevölkerung das ausbaden und
zwar wenn die wagen hat
parteivorsitzende
es muss widerspruch geben wenn kinder
stundenlang masken tragen müssen im
unterricht und nicht wenn das kritisiert
wird nur soweit und frau parteichefin
meinte reisinger sie haben einst unsere
corona politik und unseren standpunkt
auf freiwilligkeit der impfung als fett
bezeichnet
ich stelle dazu nur eine frage wissen
sie was ein bumerang ist
und der regierung rate ich
tauschen sie ihre berater aus ihrer
experten weisen sie den
regierungsexperten die türe ebenso dem
cover prognose konformation der
nationalen im krimi um gekko im
tarnanzug hören sie lieber auf ihre
fans verantwortungsbewusst auf ihre
menschlichkeit die sie sicher haben
stimmen sie nicht für das gesetz werden
sie tun aber es wird ihnen kein glück
bringen
dafür sagt singer
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident der
minister ministerinnen
regierungsbank liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen geschätzte damen und herren
eigentlich ist es ja ganz einfach es
einige der um seinen gemeinsames ziel
hoffe ich zumindest
nämlich dass diese zermürbende
aufreibenden pandemie endlich vorbei ist
und dass wir einigermaßen wieder ein
normales leben führen können wie wir es
gewohnt war die bundesregierung und vier
von fünf parteien tun alles dafür und
das heißt danke für diese breite basis
die frage die sich dann natürlich steht
wir schaffen wir denn dass diese
ersehnte normalität
schaffen wir das mit skurrilen
lebensgefährlichen ideen ich will es
nicht immer wieder erwähnen oder
schaffen wir es mit andauernden lockdown
nein es ist leider so wie es wollte
nicht die einzige mittel und
langfristige strategie ist die impfung
weil die impfung wirkt schützt und nützt
und da sind wir alle gefordert man muss
leider sagen diese ich ag oder der
individuelle egoismus müssen jetzt
einmal ein bisschen kürzer treten nach
zwei jahren
sind die zeiten vorbei wo jeder tun kann
was er will nach dem bauchgefühl handelt
oder nach dem mond stand oder den
freiheitsbegriff falsch versteht und
interpretiert ich sage ihnen sehr
geehrte damen und herren mit einem
bauchgefühl besiegt man keine pandemie
und man musik die pandemie auch nichts
wenn man alles leugnet um sinnvolle
maßnahmen weiterhin rekrutiert ich
blicke und die reihen wohl leider einige
wenige abgeordnete noch immer keine
maske tragen die derzeit bei der omicron
variante sehr gut helfen würde
es gibt eine es gibt eine wortkreation
aus pandemie und müdigkeit dieb an die
möglichkeit und diese dann die müdigkeit
spiegelt derzeit so ziemlich die
stimmung wieder die stimmung schwankt
zwischen die saison alles geht egal ich
werde mich infizieren und auch wenn er
bis zu einer freiwilligen selbst
isolation von menschen denen die
maßnahmen nicht weit genug gehen und auf
diese pandemie müdigkeit trifft jetzt
die impfpflicht und ich sage es ihnen
ganz klar immer wieder kein mensch hat
diese impfpflicht gewollt aber
wir haben es leider leider als
gesellschaft nicht geschafft ausreichend
viele menschen von der impfung zu
überzeugen und das ist schade und macht
mich auch traurig ich bin kein freund
wann ihren freund der pflicht aber sie
ist aus meiner sicht alternativlos weil
eben die durchseuchung die durchimpfung
nicht so hoch ist wie sie sein sollte
aber um positives zu erwähnen 70 prozent
aller österreicher den fähigen alter
haben sich impfen lassen aus gründen der
vernunft der medizinischen einsicht und
auch der solidarität den mitmenschen
gegenüber und dafür sage ich bei 70
prozent sage ich danke
es gibt auch fakten dazu bei dreifach
kämpften personen ist die schutzwirkung
von symptomatischen verläufen auch bei
omikron bei 70 prozent es besteht ein
schutz gegen
krankenhausaufenthalte von fast 90
prozent und schutz vor intensivstationen
über 90 prozent dass sie fakten die für
sich sprechen ich wiederhole schutz
gegen krankenhausaufenthalte micon
variante 90 prozent schutz bei
intensivstationen über 90 prozent und
das bestätigen auch meine tagtäglich
erfahrungen als arzt
omikron die neue variante ist so
ansteckend dass wir nicht daran
vorbeikommen es sei denn wir sind gut
geschützt und das sind wir eben mit der
impfung
um felix bezüglich entschädigungen bei
eventuellen impfschäden gleich
entgegenzutreten natürlich werden die
impfungen nach dem strich gesetz im
impfschaden gesetz gesetzlich verankert
für eventuelle impfschäden nach ovid
impfungen ergibt sich natürlich ein
entschädigungsanspruch das werden wir
heute auch beschließen wahrscheinlich
sogar einstimmig einige sagen jetzt seh
romy conne so harmlos was brauche ich
denn da die impfpflicht omikron ist
nicht harmlos auch wenn es vermutlich
einen tick weniger gefährlich ist als
täter und die pandemie ist auch leider
nach uni kann nicht vorbei auch wenn wir
uns das wünschen und die impfung ist
halt eine langfristige strategie ich
bezeichne diese pflicht gesetz als
impfpflicht rahmengesetz da es einen
rahmen für flexibilität gibt sozusagen
impfpflicht mit angehalten handbremse
wie manche bezeichnen es gibt mehrere
phasen erste phase ist die
informationsphase ab mitte ab märz gibt
es kontrollen erinnerungsschreiben mit
ihm vor forderungen und schlussendlich
kann es zu strafen kommen wenn es
epidemiologisch nötig ist dieser entwurf
ist ein ausbalancierter entwurf der im
plenum von 80 prozent der abgeordneten
breit mitgetragen wird und unser ziel
ist es mit einer möglichst hohen
durchimpfung die korona pandemie zu
bekämpfen und die freiheit für uns alle
wieder zu erlangen es gibt nur zwei
möglichkeiten entweder
sich impfen oder sich anzustecken der
unterschied beim impfen ist das risiko
für nebenwirkungen sehr gering die
infektion ohne im funktion war häufig zu
schweren verläufen und so longo winter
sehr geehrte damen und herren die fakten
sprechen für eine impfung fürchten sie
sich nicht der pigs ist harmlos sie
schützen sich selbst und helfen allen
anderen wir schaffen es gemeinsam
dankeschön
so wollte man die zur geschäftsordnung
des parlaments
[Applaus]
danke herr präsident der kollege sachsen
gehört gesagt dies ist die sind die
zeiten vorbei britta tun und lassen kann
was will das möchte man jetzt einmal
demokratiepolitisch stehen lassen wie
man möchte worauf ich mich in meiner
geschäftsordnungs meldungen beziehen
möchte ist die kritik die der kollege
saxinger nicht zuletzt auch an ihnen
herr präsident geübt hat und so hat der
kollege saxinger schwerstens verurteilt
dass es noch immer abgeordnete im
parlament gibt die keinem ausgetragen so
auch sie herr präsident und so auch
einige kollegen hier von der övp ich
möchte darauf hinweisen dass es eine
präsidiale gegeben hat in der vereinbart
worden ist dass wir nicht mehr
übertragen und nicht tragen von masken
sprechen werden der kollege saxinger hat
das offensichtlich nicht mehr im kopf
gehabt dass man sich darauf geeinigt hat
das in zukunft zu unterlassen möchte sie
daher bitten herr präsident noch einmal
ihren kollegen der auch sie kritisiert
hat und das massiv sie sitzen den ganzen
tag ohne maske da oben außer ihrem
kollegen auch diesen beschluss der
präsidialen erinnerung zu rufen danke
soweit gemein ist
[Musik]
herr präsident die damen und herren von
euch was auf wenn ein abgeordneter hier
heraus angeblich die würde des hohen
hauses verletzt so dagegen verstößt und
gibt es ein ordnungsruf aber wenn eine
vp abgeordneter herausgeht und die fülle
der österreichischen staatsbürgern mit
füßen treten ist es völlig wurscht
und da wundert ihr euch noch dass sich
die menschen von dieser politik
affäre damen und herren die
freiheitlichen abgeordneten werden
geschlossen sowohl die geimpften als
auch die ungeübten heute gegen diese
impfpflicht stimmen weil wir der
tiefsten überzeugung sind dass kein
abgeordneter das recht dazu hat über den
körper eines bürgers zu bestimmen so
einfach und ich kann nur an ihr gewissen
an das gewissen und dann die
menschlichkeit aller abgeordneten hier
herinnen appellieren passten sie nur auf
das sie sich morgen noch in den spiegel
blicken können passen sie auf dass
wir heute hier nicht so abheben dass sie
glauben sie könnten ihre stimme die
ihnen vom volk anvertraut wurde
missbrauchen und gegen das eigene volk
richten es ist nämlich ganz einfach kein
politiker keine regierung kein
abgeordneter hier in diesem haus hat das
recht zu bestimmen was mit dem körper
eines jeden einzelnen österreichischen
staatsbürgers passiert die körperliche
integrität
unterkörper an sich gehört jedem
menschen selbst und keinen politiker
und
und dass dieser satz für gelegt aus den
grünen sorgte wird er ganz angst und
bange der ob könne davon grünen früher
haben euch minderheiten menschenrechte
und grundrechte noch hier in was
bedeutet aber auch bei der sp früher hat
die würde des einzelnen menschen für die
sozialdemokratie noch etwas gegolten
und selbst wenn sie bei der svp nicht so
ist stelle ich mir die frage und stellt
sich viele bürger die frage wie kann man
ein land sich selbst nur so blindgänger
gewand manövrieren und gegen die wand
fahren und an einer impfpflicht
festhalten während unser nachbarland die
tschechei die impfpflicht als fehler
bereits wieder zurücknimmt während in
großbritannien fast alle maßnahmen
aufgehoben werden und während zum
beispiel in bayern zweig im einzelhandel
gekippt wurde aber absolut mit voll
kampf gegen die wand leider nicht nur
die österreichische volkspartei sondern
unser gesamtes land
aber
serie damen und herren heute geht es
mehr um jeden einzelnen abgeordneten der
bäuerinnen sitzt ich frage mich was geht
menschlich in ihnen vor was geht
menschlich in ihnen vor und wir können
sie nur mit ihrer stimme millionen von
mädchen so unter druck setzen und wir
können sie sich dann morgen noch in den
spiegel schauen das frage ich mich
wissen sie eigentlich was sie anrichten
nicht nur für demokratie und rechtsstaat
auch für die gesundheit der menschen
wissen sie was sie psychologisch mit
millionen österreichern anrichten wird
sie machen sorgen gewand wochen dass sie
sich nicht schämen und trotzdem daran
festhalten obwohl sie so einen schaden
anrichten ich muss sagen gute nacht
österreich
und abschließend darf ich mich an die
österreicherinnen und österreicher
wänden bitte verliert er mut und eure
hoffnung und bitte vergesst nicht in
einer demokratie ist immer das volk chef
und deshalb wird das ganze auch cool
ausgehen kein abgeordneter wird dafür
sorge tragen dass dieses gesetz das
jetzt daherkommt zu halten wird und
vergesst auch nicht dass jeder einzelne
abgeordnete der heutigen eure würde
stimmt passagier ist wenn er beim
nächsten wahltag zur abstimmung
schreitet die stunde null serie damen
und herren die stunde null und das
verspreche ich ihnen für vp für grüne
für sp und für neos die wird kommen und
deshalb sie ihre damen und herren werde
kollegen passen sie auf wer heute glaubt
mit seiner stimme 9 millionen
österreichern wenn mit diesem beschluss
betrifft es alle geimpft und umkämpfte
ihr recht auf selbstbestimmung über
ihren eigenen körper nehmen zu müssen
der läuft gefahr dass ihm der wähler bei
der nächsten wahl sein mandat nimmt und
das völlig zurecht seine damen und
herren
denn dann haben sie nicht verstanden und
nicht durchschaut welche große
verantwortung sie als abgeordneter gang
über jeden einzelnen staatsbürger zu
tragen haben
zumal ist ja für eine geplante reisen ja
bisher
sehr geehrter herr präsident wert der
herr vizekanzler werde mit der
bundesregierung sehr geehrte kolleginnen
kollegen der zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer ich würde also beginnen was
eint uns heute
11 glaube ich alle dass wir satt haben
dass wir unser normales leben wieder
haben wollen und dass wir die freiheit
unsere uneingeschränkte freiheit wieder
haben wollen wie wir sie vor 2020 gehabt
haben was eint uns noch es ist schon
angesprochen worden diese unfassbare
müdigkeit nicht nur die letzten tage und
wochen waren anstrengend sondern die
letzten jahre waren anstrengend für
mütter für kinder für jugendliche für
lehrerinnen und lehrer für viele viele
wirtschaftstreibende ja und auch
sicherlich für für sie hier im haus
was einst uns noch wir wollen nicht eine
situation wieder haben wo wir sehen dass
ärztinnen und ärzte pflegerinnen und
pfleger derart an der überlastung grenze
sind so dass andere krankheiten wie kobe
dazu führen dass menschen sterben müssen
unnötig sterben müssen verfrüht sterben
müssen ich habe die woche gehört dass in
österreich
der verbraucher oder zumindest der bezug
von schlafmitteln massiv gestiegen ist
das ist dramatisch
die zahlen was depressionen angeht
besonders leider unter kinder und
jugendlichen und auch leider
suizidgedanken diese zahlen sind
dramatisch es zeigt wie schlecht es den
menschen geht und wie dringend notwendig
wir alles haben dass diese zeiten
endlich hinter uns sind kinder und
jugendliche die wieder normal in die
schule gehen können
uneingeschränkt auch sport machen können
ohne maske an allen freizeit und
schulischen aktivitäten teilnehmen
können wirtschafts frei wenn die wieder
das machen können was sie tun nämlich zu
wirtschaften handelsangestellte die
nicht mehr polizistinnen oder polizisten
spielen und es ist auch ganz klar nie
wieder freiheitsbeschränkungen wie wir
sie gehabt dann ist es kein geheimnis
dass wir neos den massiven eingriffen in
die grund und freiheitsrechte der
vergangenheit sehr sehr oft sehr
kritisch gegenüber gestanden sind wo sie
nicht mitgetragen haben auch
beispielsweise den lockdown für
ungeimpfte tragen wir nicht mit weil er
für uns zu weit geht oder der lockten im
jahr zweiter für uns überschießend war
und zu weit geht was aber auch klar war
und da waren wir im meer kennen das der
weg ist der einzige weg der uns hilft
dass alle und möglichst alle impfen
gehen es gilt das was ganz zu beginn der
pandemie gesagt wurde und das ist ganz
einfach jeder und jede wird dieses virus
bekommen ja und das wird irgendwann
einmal auch einen anderen verlauf nehmen
aber wir müssen aufpassen dass es nicht
so viele gleichzeitig bekommen und zu
viele gleichzeitig kommen die noch nie
in kontakt waren mit irgendeinem
immunologischen ereignisses infektion
oder impfungen das gilt nach wie vor das
ist eigentlich sehr einfach und nichts
anderes sollte die politik zu schauen
dass nicht alle das gleichzeitig
bekommen so dass auch wenn es nicht alle
trifft aber einen teil davon schwer
trifft dann das gesundheitssystem und
überlassung spitze kommt ganzes im blick
auf das verstehen wirklich auch wirklich
alle in österreich vielleicht ist auch
die fpö dem foto ist einfach zu gering
die ist zu gering die gefahr ist zu groß
dass wir erneut wieder in eine situation
kommen und ja das sind massive
versäumnisse der bundesregierung das
können wir ihnen heute nicht ersparen
und lassen sie mich der eine sagen ich
habe im monate damit verbracht meine
fraktion hat monate damit verbracht
vorschläge zu bringen die wir positive
anreize setzen können von lotterien bis
hinauf zu anreizen über gemeinde gerade
bürgermeisterin und bürger ins boot zu
holen
monatelange versäumnisse man könnte
sagen besser spät als nie und ich finde
es gut dass es jetzt anreize gibt aber
ganz ehrlich am tag der einführung einer
impfpflicht eine milliarde über eine
lotterie auszugeben das halte ich schon
für einigermaßen skurril und ein wenig
eine
also diese massiven versäumnisse der
regierung sind da das wird ein teil sein
der begründung warum die impfquote zu
gering ist die andere teile begründung
sie vielleicht sitzt vielleicht auch
hier im wohnhaus das ist die agitation
unter anderen der fpö gegen die impfung
war das gescheit nein sicherlich nicht
oder es hat uns einfach nicht geholfen
zu oft wurde zu recht der vorwurf
gemacht der bundesregierung dass man
nicht frühzeitig gehandelt und größe zu
sein für etwaige weitere wählen und es
ist völlig klar dass diese im pflicht
die niemand wollte nicht für jetzt gilt
oder nicht für jetzt für die mikrowelle
dafür sorge tragen kann dass es jetzt
einen großen dämpfenden effekt wird aber
jedenfalls für herbst
wir haben uns sehr intensiv mit der
frage beschäftigt ob omikron etwas an
der situation ändern muss man ja man
muss das offen diskutieren und das habe
ich auch gefordert und ein des todes
nicht in die impfung wirkt und zum
anderen ist es das ist auch schon
erwähnt nicht gesagt dass es mit dieser
welle vorbei ist das nicht
beispielsweise wieder da kommt oder eine
andere variante kommt sehr oft wurde und
dass ich jetzt auch in richtung der
bevölkerung zu rechte politik der
vorwurf gemacht dass man nicht
vorausschauen handelt jetzt erstmals die
chance dass die politik schneller ist
als das virus und ich möchte noch mal
auf das thema der kisd das
gesundheitssystem zu sprechen kommen
denn die wahrheit ist eine sehr fein
hatte in wahrheit haben wir seit monaten
eine triage wenn es um krebs patienten
und patientinnen geht wir haben seit
monaten eine triage wenn es um
notwendige aber vielleicht nicht lebens
unmittelbar lebenswichtige operationen
geht und das wird einfach so hingenommen
auch von ihnen von der fpö das ist für
mich inakzeptabel und das muss beendet
werden und der grund liegt einfach daran
dass viel zu wenig menschen geimpft sind
ich weiß es ist gute positionen für und
wider die impfpflicht gibt es gibt keine
guten positionen wieder die impfung ich
verstehe auch nicht ganz warum sie sich
selber so ein punkt kann und hier nur
die impfgegner ansprechen weil es gibt
gute gründe warum man gegen eine
impfpflicht ist aber keine guten gründe
warum man gegen eine impfung ist ich
finde das hat in einer liberalen
gesellschaft auch platz aber gerade und
auch in einer liberalen partei übergangs
platz wie sie heute sehen werden aber
gerade aus dem gedanken der freiheit
heraus ist es begrünt war dass wir sagen
bescheid des einzelnen endet dort wo die
freiheit des anderen beginnt
daher sehe ich es auch aus meiner
verantwortung und die verantwortung
meiner fraktion hier heute für eine
große mehrheit zu sorgen einen breiten
konsens zu sorgen und damit einen klaren
willen auch des gesetzgebers zum
ausdruck zu bringen ich bin auch davon
überzeugt dass die menschen draußen
wollen dass wir zusammenarbeiten und
gemeinsam versuchen diese krise hinter
uns zu bringen und wir haben diesen
gesetzentwurf deutlich verbessert
gegenüber dem was ursprünglich dem tisch
gelegen ich danke auch für die
konstruktiven gespräche aber es war auch
sehr notwendig ich möchte drei punkte
herausgreifen zum einen das fixe
ablaufdatum es ist besprochen und zum
zweiten die meines erachtens dringend
nötige flexibilität samt der evaluierung
die hineingekommen ist ja das ist ein
fahren auf sicht und das ist gut und
richtig so dass wir aber gerüstet sind
für den herbst der zweite punkt ist der
uns sehr wichtig war informieren statt
strafen dass es immer der zugang den wir
gehabt haben auch das ist jetzt wirklich
und es ist kein geheimnis dass wir
gesagt haben also lasst sie 14 bis 18
jährigen heraus machen wir das ab 18 ich
möchte einen punkt noch ansprechen weil
es oft erwähnt wurde das ist das thema
der exekutive barkeit
es gibt einen grundkonsens in unserem
land und dieser grundkonsens bedeutet
dass man sich an gesetze hält und ich
appelliere an alle dass dieser
grundkonsens weiter gilt und herr
klubobmann er gilt ganz besonders auch
meines erachtens für abgeordnete die auf
diese verfassung eingeschworen sind
verlassen grundkonsens
ich finde es mehr als fair dass etwaige
strafen dem gesundheitssystem zugute
kommen das ist eine lokale zu oft
angesprochen worden das halte ich für
richtig und wichtig weil dort sind die
menschen die tagtäglich auch mit den
folgen dieser krise zu kämpfen haben und
ich sage ihnen das auch in bezug auf die
exekutive kehrt also mir sind bei aller
liebe zur verwaltungsjuristen ist ein
lieber es sind verwaltungsjuristen
überlastet als pflegerinnen und pfleger
und ärztinnen und ärzte das ist mir
weitaus lieber
der klare wille des gesetzgebers wir zum
ausdruck gebracht und klar ist auch und
das ist mir ganz besonders wichtig heute
zu sagen damit muss aber sehr klar auch
die entscheidung in richtung freiheit
weil das bedeutet dass es meines
erachtens nicht tragbar ist dass wir
weiter in london für ungeimpfte haben
dass es nicht tragbar ist das 2g im
handel handelsangestellte weiter
polizisten stehen sollen und dass es
auch einen fahrplan braucht wie wir
generell mit 1 freiheitsbeschränkungen
etwas sperrstunde oder zweig abfahren
das hat dann für mich keine platz mehr
weil dann muss wirklich der schritt
gemacht werden wieder in ein normales
leben
impfen minister richtige weg bitte
lassen sie sich impfen aber dann muss
auch klar sein die freiheit muss wieder
vollständig gewährleistet danke
so wollten wir es dafür scheinbar bitte
sehr
danke herr präsident sehr geehrt den
ministerinnen und minister
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
sehr geehrte damen und herren zu hause
an den bildschirmen
ganz ehrlich für einen grünen ist das
hier heute keine leichte übung
das ist nicht das gesetz dass ich mir
immer vorgestellt habe dass ich hier
unbedingt lehrerinnen verteidigen möchte
und dass ich hier beschließen möchte das
ist schon auch für uns eine durchaus
schwierige übung aber es ist auch eine
notwendigkeit und es frei nach face no
more jetzt hat dörte jobportal monster
cdu
und frau kollegin fürst ich möchte schon
noch ganz kurz auf das replizieren wo
sie es gesagt haben sie haben jetzt
dieses hearing so ist larifari
kaffeeklatsch ein bisserl auch
dargestellt
liebe kolleginnen fürst da waren fünf
expertinnen und experten dort die
wirklich einen sehr wertvollen beitrag
geliefert haben die sich sehr gut
eingebracht haben und für diejenigen die
sich das mit eigenen augen ansehen
möchten kann ich es nur empfehlen das
ist auf der homepage des parlaments nach
seebach es ist etwas über drei stunden
dauern und das sieht man dass die ganze
geschichte etwas anders war es ist eben
die kolleginnen fürst dargestellt hat
aber kommen wir zum eigentlichen thema
kombi wir tatsächlich aber es gesagt
weil es notwendig ist weil es eben die
ultima ratio dieser pandemie ist weil
wir endlich ein werkzeug brauchen um
auch im herbst im kommenden herbst
diesen jahres eben normalität wieder zu
haben und damit wir nicht wieder in
einem pandemie herbst und in weiterer
folge in einem pandemie winter kippen es
geht darum aber auch weil wir in der
abgelaufenen vierten infektionswelle
also in dieser vierten pandemiewelle
sehr gut gesehen haben im
internationalen vergleich was
herauskommt wenn es eine gute eine hohe
durchimpfungsrate gibt länder mit
deutlich besseren bildraten sind besser
durchgekommen die haben zwar auch hohe
instanzen gab aber auch sehr sehr viele
infektionen gehabt aber deutlich weniger
menschen die dort hospitalisiert werden
mussten und deutlich weniger menschen
die dort leben auf die intensivstation
gelandet sind im gegensatz zu uns hier
in österreich
das heißt wir sehen die impfstoffe gegen
kobe wirken gegen schwere verläufe gegen
intensiv pflichtige verläufe das sehen
wir aber auch an einer ganz anderen
sache die arge serviert für uns wenn wir
diese
schutzmaßnahmen verordnungen im
hauptausschuss beschließen dann er oh ja
die matisse für uns die generelle
situation und dort ist eines einer der
faktoren die man da eben immer auch ums
leben anschauen wie schaut auf den
intensivstationen aus und seit monaten
seit zumindest seit mitte oktober wenn
das jetzt richtig und kopf habe es ist
immer dasselbe bild drei viertel der
wegen co wird auf der intensivstation
betreuten patientinnen und patienten
sind umkämpft ein viertel dienst und in
der heute in der früh vorliegenden zahl
ist es dann noch ein bisserl extremer
geworden 18 prozent geimpft
82% umgehen das ist die situation das
sind zahlen das sind daten das sind
fakten das heißt die impfung senke das
risiko schwer zu erkranken sie senkt das
risiko intensiv pflichtig zu erkranken
sie dämpft das infektionsgeschehen in
der bevölkerung und sie zwingt das virus
je mehr menschen geimpft sind zu einem
anderen infektions verhalten all das ist
evident all das spricht für eine hohe
ihn fragte demgegenüber gilt die frage
zu klären wie weit darf eben der staat
in die individuelle persönliche freiheit
eingreifen da wird auch dann meine
kollegin agnes prammer mit sicherheit
noch mit genauer darauf eingehen aber
beim expertinnen jährigen am montag war
das auch ein zentraler punkt und bei
diesem expertinnen hierin ist es daneben
auch darum gegangen ist ein
funktionierendes gesundheitswesen ein
dringendes gesellschaftliches bedürfnis
für das leben der stadt dementsprechend
eingreifen darf
darüber möchte bevor ich auf diese frage
noch eingehen möchte ich noch kurz auf
das begutachtungsverfahren denn wir
haben das sehr ernst genommen so wie es
gute gründe tradition ist haben wir uns
eben auch dann gemeinsam mit der spd
gemeinsam mit den neros gemeinsam mit
unserem koalitionspartner mit den
sozialpartnern mit expertinnen und
experten die stellungnahmen ganz genau
angeschaut und haben sehr so vieles auch
verändert kollegin meindl reisinger
hatte er schon ein bisserl was für ihre
fraktion ebenda dargelegt was ihnen eben
auch sehr wichtig war dem kann ich mich
anschließend 18 statt 14 3 phasen statt
einem stand bestrafungs modell habe ich
mir aufgeschrieben vermehrte aufklärung
mehr anreize flankierend zur pflicht
dazu ein konsultationsmechanismus mit
expertinnen und experten ob die
verhältnismäßigkeit weiterhin gegeben
ist das letztere insbesondere dann und
diese ganzen verordnungen auch im
zusammenspiel mit dem nationalrat
mittels dem hauptausschuss
dementsprechend machen die
parlamentarische kontrolle über dieses
gesetzes zu sichern und zu ermöglichen
und in diesem zusammenhang möchte ich
auch hier zwei abänderungsanträge noch
einbringen zu diesem tagesordnungspunkt
1 mal eben zum cupid also mit 19
impfpflicht gesetzt da geht es eben
einer setzung die anpassung des titels
es geht um die definition des genesenen
status in diesem zusammenhang und es
geht eben nochmals um diese ganz genau
ausdifferenzierung dieses begleitenden
monitorings wo er auch der kollege lag
am montag nochmals diese frage gestellt
hat wie schaut's daraus mit den drei
monaten waren greift es das haben wir
alles hier drinnen genauer eben dann
definiert und eben auch genau auf den
punkt gebracht es wird auch gerade jetzt
im saal verteilt und zum anderen weil
wir auch hier das epidemie gesetz und
das kommt maßnahmen gesetzt eben mit
verhandeln möchte ich auch hier einen
abänderungsantrag noch einbringen wo es
eben noch darum geht was passiert bei
wiederholter missachtung von kogit
auflagen das was werden dann in diesem
abwanderungs antrag noch genau drinnen
definieren aber was sind schon
festhalten möchte auch in diesem
zusammenhang noch und das ist mir auch
wichtig weil es eben auch draußen in der
breiten welt und weil es auch von der
fpö immer so getan wird als ob es immer
hier nur um einen impfstoff gehen würde
um sozusagen um diese neben der
impfstoff von diesen umstrittenen es
geht um alle impfstoff für alle
impfstoffe die in österreich zugelassen
sind die von der ema dementsprechend das
zertifikat habe alle diese stoffe werden
natürlich in der öffentlich
berücksichtigt also auch diese neuen
impfstoff auf die der eine oder andere
erwartet wichtig ist aber der impfstoff
muss sicher sein und dem stoff muss
zugelassen sein und dies bedingt
dementsprechend macht dann die
entsprechende qualität und eben die
sicherheit umso wichtiger
umso wichtiger wird auch werden in den
nächsten wochen und monaten weiterhin
aufeinander zuzugehen weiter in diesem
diskurs zu führen und dazu gehört aber
eben auch dann zahlen daten und fakten
anzuerkennen
und dazu gehört es auch evidenzen
anzuerkennen und dazu gehört es auch das
thema cupid in seiner breite der
auswirkungen auf unser gesundheitswesen
zu sehen und nicht immer nur dort das
statistik raus zu zupfen und dort ein
bisschen einzelfall eben hoch zu
stilisieren und dann eben von diesem
einzelfall auf das gesamte zu schließen
so wie sie die kolleginnen und kollegen
der fpö so gerne tun um eben das heute
so zitiert die politische kleingeld eben
zu schlagen uns ist klar in dieser
pandemie ändert sich jeden tag etwas und
für die aktuelle umgekommen variante ist
auch dieses impfpflicht gesetz eben zu
spät dieses impfpflicht gesetz setzt
dort an wo wir eben im kommenden herbst
leben sind und es geht eben darum ums
leben vorzubereiten denn wir wissen aus
heutiger sicht nicht was uns im herbst
im winter im kommenden eben dann auch
erwartet welche variante daneben
dementsprechend uns eben fordert es geht
aber und ich hab das jetzt schon einmal
gesagt um dieses dringende
gesellschaftliche bedürfnis eines
funktionierenden gesundheitssystems
und das hat nicht gesagt in diesem in
diesem expertinnen hearing das hat der
fpö experte dr geistlicher ins spiel
gebracht und ich glaube wenn ein
gesundheitssystem ein theaterbus des
gesundheitswesen wie das österreichische
mehrfach kurz vor dem kollabieren war
dann ist die frage nach dem dringenden
gesellschaftlichen bedürfnis eines
funktionierenden gesundheitssystems aus
meiner sicht geklärt wenn ich noch dazu
weiß dass die impfung unser bestes
mittel unser bestes werkzeug in diesem
zusammenhang ist
abschließend möchte ich mich so wie es
auch meine klubobfrau heute schon getan
hat möchte ich mich auch nochmals
ausdrücklich bedanken bei der sp bei den
leos ich möchte mich natürlich beim
koalitionspartner bedanken bei den
vielen expertinnen und experten bei den
mitarbeiterinnen im ministerium von
minister mückstein aber natürlich auch
beim verfassungsdienst bei den
expertinnen die ich auf der welt hatte
die ehrenamtliche beraterin zur seite
gestanden sind die wirklich wichtige und
wertvolle ein als er sich wirklich
wertvoll leben hier auch hat man auch
eingebracht haben das war ein starkes
stück arbeit ein schweres stück arbeit
aber ich hab' ich habe es am montag
schon einmal gesagt ich bin aus dem
gesundheitsausschuss am montag mit
erhobenen haupt hinaus gegangen weil ich
finde wir haben hier wirklich ein gutes
gesetz gemeinsam hingebracht und da
sieht man auch wenn man will dann können
wir alle gemeinsam etwas erreichen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der fpö ihr
seid eingeladen ihr könnt auch zustimmen
es tut nicht weh und es würde unserem
land viel mehr bringen als diese
kleinkind hoffte art und weise dass ich
mag nicht ich mag nicht die ihr seit
zwei jahren an den tag legt in diesem
sind dankeschön
der beiden anträge sind abrechnungs
anlage sind wir uns gemäß eingebracht
ausreichend unterstützen stehen somit in
verhandlung zu wort gemeldet ist
vielen dank herr präsident geschätzte
kolleginnen und kollegen ich muss
gestehen seit ich hier im parlament in
ist das definitiv eine der schwierigsten
entscheidungen die ich heute treffen
muss und sie fällt mir deswegen so
schwer weil ich nicht so kommen hätte
müssen und weil wir monatelang auch von
diesen entwicklungen wir alle
miteinander gewarnt haben und umso
schlimmer finde ich jetzt das auf dem
platz auf dem normalerweise der
bundeskanzler der republik österreich
sitzt jetzt nur eine braune
herrenhandtasche steht und der stadt
dass es eine entschuldigung des
bundeskanzlers gibt immerhin auch vp
chef steht hier nur diese braune herrn
handtasche und eine aktentasche bitte
verteilung also offensichtlich gehört in
den vize-kanzler kogler ist eine
aktentasche aber ich wollte darauf
hinaus dass der bundeskanzler nicht
anwesend ist und je hatte ich hier die
chance gehabt hätte auch offen und
ehrlich zu sagen dass es ihm leidtut
dass es überhaupt so weit gekommen ist
doch war kein naturgesetz dass wir in
österreich erlebt haben und das war
nicht unfähigkeit der regierung alleine
sondern es war auch begründet dass der
öbb
parteipolitik wichtiger war als gutes
krisenmanagement
und
es waren die bürger aus und maurers die
immer wieder bei jeder kritik gesagt
haben das ist alles nicht so schlimm wir
können das ja alle miteinander auch
nachvollziehen es war die landtagswahl
in oberösterreich wo expertinnen und
experten nachforschung gewarnt haben
gewarnt haben dass maßnahmen zu treffen
sind aber die waren in oberösterreich
wichtiger sagt man nichts getan wenn man
versprochen dass alles vorbei ist und
der coole sommer schon damals war es ein
kurzes formuliert hat und das war
situation in salzburg wo menschen hat
der intensivstation ums überleben
gekämpft haben und haslauer rausgegangen
ist und virologen virologen verspottet
hat das war die ausgangssituation vor
der wir alle gestanden sind es hätte
nicht so weit kommen müssen es hätte
nicht so weit kommen wissen haben wir
stehen in einer situation wo wir
verantwortung übernehmen muss und wir
alle auch das wahrnehmen müssen was uns
ärztinnen und ärzte jetzt sagen dass die
impfung eine schutz bietet und wir alle
gefordert sind auch aus dieser krise
herauszukommen und herbert kickl sagt
das ganz offen in deine richtung auch
ich sage das ganz offen wenn ich die
warnung von ärztinnen und ärzte gibt und
wir alle auch miteinander hoffentlich
denen vertrauen dass sie das beste für
ihre patientinnen und patienten tun da
muss meiner situation wenn das haus
brennt miteinander auch beim löschen
mithelfen und muss den mut haben und die
verantwortung übernehmen für schwierige
entscheidungen mit der hand nach wird
die hand im hosensack vorstellen für die
hemden hosen dastehen und nichts tun das
ist eigentlich auch
dem herbert krämer die inneneinrichter
nicht würdig du hast mal innenminister
du wirst jetzt keine angst haben man
kann doch in dieser situation auch mut
und verantwortung übernehmen und nur
weil es jetzt in tätergruppe aus
oberösterreich die msg gibt das kann
doch nicht sein dass ich dann auch seine
e-mails mutigen partei wie der spd
geworden dass man auch diesen gegenwind
fürchtet und nur weil die fsm sg jetzt
hier einen druck macht seite nicht mehr
in der lage zu ihrer haltung zu stehen
und dafür zu kämpfen dass die gesundheit
der menschen immer wichtiger sein muss
als parteitaktik immer wichtiger sein
muss als parteitaktik und
holte die warten in den letzten monaten
und dort auch die fpö das hätte nichts
besser aber die öbb ihr habt es nicht
leichter gemacht diese ganzen komischen
die warten über das entwurmung mittel
über bitterstoffe über sonnenlicht dass
das alles hilft das war doch unwürdig
das war doch ein wenig und hat den
menschen in den krankenhäusern den
patienten patienten aber vor allem den
leuten die uns leben von menschen
kämpfen nicht weitergeholfen und desire
tanz dass man dann zurückrudern müssen
und dass du mit südkorea überzeugt
dass diese tour mittel ersetzt die
impfung endet also in wahrheit glaubt
jetzt doch an er an die impfung das ist
doch auch unwürdig dass man irgendwie
mit immerhin schichten raus geht wenn
man glaubt man muss was er finden
anstatt dass in dieser schwierigen
situation verantwortung übernimmt und
verantwortung übernehmen das machen wir
alle miteinander indem wir sagen dass
wir dieses gesetz miteinander auch
gemeinsam mit unzähligen experten
experten verhandelt haben und vor allem
dafür garantieren dass dieses gesetz
keinen tag eine stunde keine minute und
keine sekunde länger in kraft ist als
unbedingt notwendig dafür sorgen wir
gemeinsam mit ärztinnen und ärzten und
mit verfassungsexperten experten mit
einem monitoren das ist etwas was man
ganz konkret bunkern dafür aber krisen
management heißt auch verantwortung
übernehmen in schwierigen zeiten und
auch wächst gegenwind gibt und da ist
keine zeit für populistische tour
sondern ich würde wirklich bieten dass
er versucht menschenleben zu retten dass
wir alles tun auch um miteinander aus
dieser krise herauszukommen nur herum
schimpfen und die visagen bitterstoffe
über medien und wasser immer das wird
uns nicht weiterbringen aber es weiß in
wahrheit auch die fpö
[Applaus]
ministerpräsident geschätzte ministerin
gesetzte minister insbesondere herr
gesundheitsminister
wir laden euch alles haben heute euch
abgenommen hier in diesem haus ein über
dieses gesetz und zu begleiten
mitzudenken und am ende des tages die
entscheidung zu treffen ob es sich
wirklich auszahlt ein impfpflicht gesetz
zu beschließen aber nicht denn ihr
selbst und ich appelliere an den
gesundheitsminister haben selbst in
dieses gesetz die impfpflicht nicht
eingezogen die haben sie ausgeschlossen
sie haben in paragraf 1 absatz 3
hineingeschrieben unmittelbare befehls
und zwangsgewalt ist ausgeschlossen das
heißt kein österreicher und keine
österreicher ist verpflichtet sich
impfen zu lassen keiner aber sie sind
hergegangen und habe es einfach gemacht
sie haben ja eh gratuliert dass die
krankenanstalten gefüllt werden jetzt
mit kohle nämlich insofern dass sie alle
österreich und österreicher die sich
nicht impfen lassen zwangsweise eine
strafe auferlegen werden das ist ihr
gesetz das ist ja gesetzt wo sie her
gehen und sich sogar dreisten das
herunterzubrechen auf die 14-jährige auf
die 14 bis 18 jährigen und auf dieser
basis her gingen obwohl sie und wenn sie
ihre stellungnahmen gelesen habt sowohl
die organisation der pädiatrie ehesten
als auch die hebammen sie zwingen darauf
hingewiesen haben dass sie das nicht
machen sollen nehmen sie 14 bis 18
jährige nicht hinein das haben sie ins
gesetz geschrieben dann gehen sie einen
schritt weiter sie nehmen das heraus und
nehmen diese jugendlichen die nicht
vielleicht die dispositions und
diskussions fähigkeit haben sogar so
weit dass sie durch ihren gesetzlichen
vertreter nämlich und das ist das
schlimme dabei zum beispiel einen
behinderten kinder oder einen der die
einsichtsfähigkeit nicht hat auferlegen
dass er eine entscheidung darüber
treffen muss dass er sich impfen lassen
muss und wenn es gut und das nicht macht
dann was jetzt folgen das dann muss der
gesetzliche vertreter entscheiden
darüber so das heißt die strafen doppelt
und das ist in ihrer begriffsbestimmung
in § 1 1 trennen aber sie gehen noch
weiter weil sie den innenminister den
ehemaligen angegriffen haben und da
dreisten sich eine wunderbare
darstellung zu machen vom montag und
kein mensch hat irgendwann einmal sich
diese stellungnahme der arge daten
durchgelesen haben sie denn irgendeine
vorstellungskraft was in dieser arge
daten drinnen gestanden ist sie gehen
nämlich sie setzen ein gesetz in kraft
mit ersten februar und haben die
technischen voraussetzungen dafür nicht
die elga daten ist nicht in der lage die
daten zu liefern aber sie wir gehen auf
der anderen seite her und schauen sich
eine datenschutz grund verordnungen
ergeben einen tipp mit sollte sie auch
öffentlich rechtlich durchsetzbar sein
dann ist jeder einzelfall mit 20
millionen euro zu bestrafen oder mit
vier prozent des unternehmens österreich
100 milliarden umsatz lasst uns 400
milliarden euro herrichten weil das wir
dir strafräumen seinen am ende des tages
und jetzt immer nur auf der
einfachgesetzlichen ebenen busch und so
ein mist drinnen ist in diesem gesetz
und jetzt sind wir noch nicht drüber
gegangen über die verhältnismäßigkeit im
verfassungsrang das heißt sie gehen her
und sie wissen seit der entscheidung vom
26 03 2012 entscheidung um 466 oder
andere mehr dass auch die europäischen
grundrechtscharta eine ganz klare
vorgabe beim eingriff in die gesundheit
beziehungsweise in die körperliche
unversehrtheit des menschen ausgemacht
hat sie zitieren immer den tschechischen
fall der überhaupt keine daten grundlage
gehabt hat um diese verhältnis mit jesus
urteil vom europäischen gerichtshof
ziehen und das wird ihre nagelprobe
werden sie haben so viele eingriffe in
die verhältnismäßigkeit von einzelnen
grundrechten das letztendlich jeder
verfassungsrichter bereits jetzt im kern
sendung stars dieses gesetz aufgehoben
worden und das ist alles was sie bis
jetzt mit ihren eigenen fach werden
nicht in die lage gesetze umzusetzen
übrig bleibt strafen übrig bleibt im
grunde genommen dass sie jene
österreicher am ende des tages wenn er
dem robert-koch-institut sich folgend
alle drei monate eine straff erhält mit
2400 euro belasten sie vor schulen die
österreicher dadurch dass sie ihre freie
meinungsäußerung zwangsweise durchsetzen
wollen mit einem ins gesetz das ist
einfach wird ablehnen und es ist auch
nicht nachvollziehbar von unserer seite
her
denken sie an die verfassung denken sie
an hans kelsen der uns das vorgegeben
hat und ganz klar dargelegt hat dass die
grundrechte das höchste gut der
österreicher sind wir sind auf diese
verfassung verpflichtet entscheiden sie
nach ihrem gewissen und nicht nach
partei schaltung
zu
wollen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
der vize kanzler geschätzte minister
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren ich
möchte auf vier punkte eingehen das
erste ist wie es denn zurzeit die
aktuelle corona situation das zweite wie
ist diese stufenweise implementierung
die in diesen impfpflicht gesetz
vorgesehen ist zu verstehen dass dritte
ist warum ist hier viel flexibilität
eingebaut wurden und das vierte was ist
das ziel das wir damit anstreben sie
fangen mit den ersten an wie schaut's
mit omikron oder überhaupt mit der
korona pandemie derzeit aus wir haben
heute sind die inzidenz von etwa 1500
prognostiziert für die nächste zeit wird
zwischen zwei und dreitausend wenn man
in länder schaut die in der dynamik vor
uns sind sieht man dass die ganzen
steilen anstieg haben wegen der
infektiösen omikron variante und das mit
einer gewissen zeitlichen verzögerung
dass sich dann auch auf die spitals
belebung aus wirkt weniger als es bei
den bisherigen varianten war aber doch
sehr deutlich angesichts der enormen
infektions dynamik warum es jetzt milder
verläuft zum einen die hoffnung an sich
dass die variante etwas milder sein
könnte zum anderen aber doch durch den
schutz den die impfung bereits bietet so
dass es sehr viel milde und
asymptomatische verläufe gibt aber diese
auswirkung auf die hospitalisierung
zeigt es ist weiter handlungsbedarf
gegeben
nun haben wir ein gesetz das eine
stufenweise implementierung vorsieht
zuerst kommt die beratung die
information erst ab mitte märz kann es
dann punktuell zu strafen kommen wobei
es auf hinweisen möchte dass das gesetz
in finanzieller hinsicht lediglich
obergrenzen der strafe festlegt und
explizit steht das auf die finanzielle
leistungsfähigkeit rücksicht genommen
werden und die dritte stufe wo wirklich
an die breite bevölkerung heran getreten
wird die ist kein automatismus sondern
bei einer verordnung von einer
zustimmung wiederum von seiten des
hauptausschusses und
das sind wesentliche aspekte der
flexibilisierung und die brauchen wir
denn
bei der beurteilung der
verhältnismäßigkeit
sind viele variable zu berücksichtigen
die infektiosität des virus die schwere
der erkrankung die schutzwirkung der
impfung die möglichkeit weitere
therapien die durchimpfungsrate
möglicherweise neue optionen auch in
richtung impfung und all das kann man
nicht von einem heutigen standpunkt für
zwei jahre voraus prognostizieren das
muss wirklich aktuell entschieden werden
können deshalb diese
verordnungsermächtigungen und deshalb
aber auch das dreimonatige monitor hängt
die laufende evaluierung mit der
verpflichtung das auch dem parlament zur
kenntnis zu bringen und diese
verordnungen wiederum sind
hauptausschuss pflichtig so dass auch da
die kontrolle gegeben ist und
warum brauchen wir diese flexibilität
schauen wir in die zukunft was wollen
wir erreichen
ich warne davor jetzt nur stur auf
omikron zu schauen das ist eine
momentaufnahme in einem sehr dynamischen
pandemie verlauf wir wissen nicht wie es
kommt ja mal was sehr gute gründe
anzunehmen dass wir eine breite
immunität in der bevölkerung trafen
damit welche varianten auch immer in
zukunft kommen können welche wählen auch
vielleicht auf uns zukommen können sie
nie mehr diesen effekt entfalten können
dem in der vergangenheit erlebt haben
und wir wieder zu einem normalen leben
zurückfinden können das ist unser
gemeinsames ziel ging es gemeinsam
danke
so wird die meines dafür nachgewiesen
der präsident der vize-kanzler sehr
geehrte damen und herren auf der
regierungsbank gesundheitsminister
insbesondere eine impfpflicht so wie wir
sie heute diskutieren ist
selbstverständlich ein schwerwiegender
eingriff in grundrechte
und freiheitsrechte und solche eingriffe
wird der kollege magath schon hans
kelsen vorher strapaziert hat können nur
dann gerechtfertigt sein wenn es
einerseits ein öffentliches interesse an
diesem eingriff gibt wenn der eingriff
geeignet ist das geplante ziel zu
erreichen und wenn eine
interessensabwägung standhält das ist
ein öffentliches interesse daran gibt
dass die intensivstationen nicht
überprüft werden es glaube ich
unbestritten dass eine impfpflicht auch
hilft diesem ziel näher zu kommen weil
je mehr menschen geimpft sind desto
weniger land auf der intensivstation ist
glaube ich auch sehr klar die schwierige
frage und das ist die die wir heute
beantworten müssen ist ob eine
impfpflicht einer interessensabwägung
standhält und wenn ich mir anschaue was
ist für andere optionen gibt und welche
anderen optionen die bundesregierung in
den letzten jahren so ausprobiert hat
dann finden wir in wirklichkeit die
regelmäßigen lockt aus und lockt uns
sind ebenso drastische eingriffe in die
grund und freiheitsrechte von allen
menschen in österreich
londons haben kinder davon abgehalten
das sind die schule gehen können dass
sie dort bildung genießen können lockt
uns haben kinder von abgehalten dass
ihre freunde treffen können dass serie
großeltern treffen können diese lockt
uns haben jungen menschen monate ihres
lebens gestohlen die wir ihnen nie
wieder zurückgeben können und sie haben
dazu geführt dass das was wir über
monate diskutiert haben diese triage auf
der kinderpsychiatrie schon längst
realität war wo wir erst begonnen haben
darüber zu diskutieren
lockt das haben unternehmerinnen
unternehmen verboten dass ihr geschäft
aufsperren haben dazu geführt dass
unfassbar fleißige menschen die nichts
falsch gemacht haben ihren beruf nicht
mehr nachgehen können und von heute
nicht wussten wie sie ihren
lebensunterhalt bestreiten sollen sie
haben von menschen und vielen menschen
in österreich leider auch die
wirtschaftliche existenz vernichtet
lockt uns haben die psychische
gesundheit von unfassbar vielen menschen
in österreich nachhaltig belastet und
wir haben auch über die nächsten jahre
und jahrzehnte damit kämpfen müssen das
wird diesen menschen helfen können
allen menschen in österreich wurden doch
lockt uns die grundlegenden grund und
freiheitsrechte genommen sie durften
kein soziales leben haben sie durften
keine freunde treffen ihre familien
nicht und viele dürften ihren beruf
nicht nachgehen und solche lockt uns
sind auf dauer nicht zu rechtfertigen
wir haben mitbekommen was das der
unfassbare wirtschaftliche und soziale
auswirkungen gegeben hat durch diese
lockten zum wir haben miterlebt was es
völlig absurden dazu das ausmaß
angenommen hat und deswegen sind solche
lockt uns auf dauer schlichtweg nicht
mehr tragbar
dieser diese unfassbaren grundrechts
einschränkungen für alle menschen in
österreich aber insbesondere für die
mehr als 75 prozent der menschen
österreich die sich mehrfach geimpft
haben die sich mehrfach die infra um
sich zu schützen und andere zu schützen
die sich regelmäßig testen um sich zu
schützen und andere zu schützen aber für
all der menschen in österreich diese
unfassbaren grundrechts einschränkungen
können unternehmen wenn wir diese im
pflicht beschließen dafür brauchen wir
dieser impfpflicht und gerade ich es
überzeugter liberaler kommen am schluss
bei dieser interessensabwägung zu dem
ergebnis dass eine impfpflicht deswegen
zu rechtfertigen ist weil wir es damit
schaffen und weil sie das gelindere
mittel ist um all diese anderen
unfassbaren grundrechts einschränkungen
die dann endlich ein ende zu bereiten
und und somit das ganze
verfassungskonform ist uns ein wichtiges
anliegen war haben wir mehrere
vorschläge auch in die verhandlungen
eingebracht so ist das prinzip beraten
statt strafe im vordergrund es gibt in
mehreren phasen es wird keinesfalls
ersatzfreiheitsstrafen geben für
menschen die nicht bereit sind sich zu
impfen der hauptausschuss ist
eingebunden in die wesentlichen fragen
es muss wenn sich herausstellt dass die
impfung nicht wirkt weil eine andere
variante kommt sie schnellstmöglich
aufgehoben werden die impfpflicht es
wird keine impfpflicht für kinder und
jugendliche geben und das ganze gesetz
hat ein fixes ablaufdatum
ich würde ganz gerne abschließend noch
ein appell ihnen mitgeben der uns
vielleicht in zukunft erspart dass wir
so schwerwiegende fragen uns überhaupt
diese fragen und steigen müsse nun
entscheiden müssen ich bin nämlich
überzeugt davon dass ein wesentlicher
grund für diese absurde impfskepsis in
österreich historisch bedingtes sie so
weil über jahrzehnte leider viele
meinungsmache rinnen und meinungsmacher
in österreich eine unerträgliche
wissenschafts weiblichkeit an den tag
gelegt haben und diese gefördert haben
es wurde eine aus meiner sicht nicht
nachvollziehbare skepsis gegenüber der
pharma branche und den tag gelegt es
wurden verschwörungstheorien in der in
die diskussion eingebracht gegen eine
branche die nachweislich durch die
erfindung von impfungen aber millionen
menschenleben gerettet hat und
es wurden auch
und es wurden auch und werden immer noch
absurder baisch informationen im
zusammenhang mit gentechnik verbreitet
ohne dass wir uns überhaupt jemals der
diskussion stellen was es denn für
vorteile geben kann durch rote und auch
grüne gentechnik
und danke plan auch diese ganzen
verschwörungstheorien rund um
irgendwelche philanthropischen
milliardäre die baumesse unwidersprochen
stehen gelassen werden und
weiterverbreitet werden
und wenn ich dann gleichzeitig auch noch
mit krieg das oder brechts oder gerade
deswegen esoterischen lehren mehr
geglaubt wird als der wissenschaft wenn
ich in apotheken um japanischer mittel
als gleichwertigen dem echter medizin
vorfinden dann brauche ich mich nicht
wundern dass menschen in österreich
wirklich glauben dass sie gegen ein
virus mit einem pferde entwurmung
mitteln vorgehen können wenn
diese pandemie wenn diese pandemie eine
klitzekleine chance mit sich bringt dann
ist es hoffentlich die chance dass wir
diese unerträgliche wissenschafts
freundlichkeit und diese skepsis
gegenüber der schulmedizin ein ende
bereiten vertrauen sie der wissenschaft
und lassen sie sich impfen
zu wort gemeldet die abgeordnete prammer
vielen danke präsident
der bundesregierung hatte kolleginnen
und kollegen liebe zuseherinnen und
zuseher ja wir beschließen heute eine
verpflichtende schutzimpfung
wenn man mit menschen redet die
vorbehalte gegen eine solche
verpflichtung haben dann werden oft
unterschiedliche alternativen
vorgeschlagen was man sonst machen
könnte eine davon ist dass man menschen
die sich nichts haben impfen lassen
einen selbstbehalt für die
behandlungskosten vorschreibt oder man
könnte auch ihre
krankenversicherungsbeiträge erhöhen
manche gehen sogar soweit
zu meinen man könnte sie nicht behandeln
wenn andere auch gleichzeitig eine
behandlung brauchen wir sind tatsächlich
ernst gemeinte vorschläge gekommen aber
so ticken wir nicht und so funktioniert
auch unser system nicht unser system
basiert auf solidarität
wir haben als stadt den anspruch uns die
pflicht ein gesundheitssystem zu
schaffen und zu erhalten das für alle
die es benötigen die optimale behandlung
gewährleistet
wir alle bezahlen nach dem gleichen
schema in dieses system ein und wir alle
haben das gleiche recht darauf dass in
anspruch zu nehmen wir alle haben das
recht dass uns geholfen wird wenn wir
krank werden und zwar bedingungslos
niemand da vorher gefragt werden ob sie
alles getan hat um nicht krank zu werden
niemandem darf gesagt werden du musst
dich hinten anstellen du hast dann zu
hohes risiko auf sich genommen
so funktioniert unser gesundheitssystem
gleiches recht für alle gleiche
behandlung für alle
wir stehen jetzt vor der situation das
ist das system und seine grenzen gelangt
dass menschen die eine behandlung
brauchen die nicht bekommen weil
gleichzeitig zu viele zu viele menschen
krank sind und wir wissen was der grund
dafür ist der grund ist die kurve 19
pandemie und wir haben ein mittel um das
zu verhindern wir haben ein mittel mit
dem wir sehr viele menschen davor
bewahren können schwer zu erkranken das
ist die schutzimpfung
19 ist da es wird nicht einfach weggehen
und es wird auch nicht einfach aufhören
aber wir können uns dagegen wehren dass
es auf dauer unser leben bestimmt durch
die schutzimpfung können wir uns davor
schützen schwer zu erkranken und dadurch
dass so viele von uns durch diese
impfung geschützt werden werden kaum
noch menschen schwer kranken und dadurch
schützen wir unser gesundheitssystem
dadurch verhindern wir dass menschen
nicht die behandlung bekommen die sie
brauchen und die sie auch haben könnten
wenn nicht so viele gleichzeitig krank
werden wir das sind wir alle wir alle
die wir in diesem land leben wir alle
die wir dieses system mit unseren
beiträgen erhalten wir alle die wir uns
die bestmögliche behandlung erwarten
dürfen und wir alle müssen auch dazu
beitragen dass dieses system am laufen
erhalten werden kann die verpflichtung
zur schritten zur schutzimpfung ist
nicht eine erfindung des
gesundheitsministers auch nichts der
regierungsparteien die verpflichtet zur
schutzimpfung entspringt unserem
solidarischen system
wir alle wir dürfen uns darauf verlassen
dass es für uns da ist wenn wir es
brauchen das geeignete mittel um es zu
schützen ist die schutzimpfung also
müssen wir uns impfen lassen wir alle
ich finde es auch schade dass wir in
einer aufgeklärten gesellschaft diesen
selbstverständlichen beitrag in einem
gesetz festschreiben müssen aber aus
verantwortung für das gesundheitssystem
und für uns alle die wir uns zu recht
darauf verlassen dass es da ist wenn wir
es brauchen müssen wir das jetzt machen
die rückseite eines jeden rechts ist
eine pflicht und dem recht auf optimale
behandlung steht die pflicht gegenüber
dieses system zu schützen wir können das
auch schaffen
indem wir immer und immer wieder lockt
uns machen und alles herunter fahren und
zu spüren wir können das auch machen
indem wir weiterhin menschen die nicht
geschützt sind um sie vor der ansteckung
zu bewahren von menschenansammlungen
fernhalten oder wir können uns impfen
lassen die schützin vom berg sie ist
sicher und sie ist das geeignetste
mittel um uns zu schützen und damit das
system zu schützen also haben wir die
pflicht sie in anspruch zu nehmen so
funktioniert unser solidarisches system
und nichts anderes ist es was wir in
diesem gesetz festschreiben
nächster redner herr abgeordneter alois
stöger
danke frau präsidentin liebe mitglieder
der bundesregierung wir kolleginnen und
kollegen wo es ihm ist 1948 die
allgemeine erklärung der menschenrechte
in der uno-generalversammlung
erklärt worden ist hat seine
lebenserwartung für männer von 62 jahren
man hat die allgemeine erklärung der
menschenrechte vor dem hintergrund
gemacht dass man ein regime überwunden
hat wo menschenrechte keine rolle
gespielt haben und wohl
wissenschaftlichkeit keine rolle
gespielt hat sondern wo leid eigentlich
ganz cool stuhl und meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren möchten über
lebenserwartung reden wir haben 1948 die
männer eine lebenserwartung von 62
jahren gehabt und wir haben heute eine
lebenserwartung von nahezu 80 jahren bei
geburt
und diese 18 jahre die da dazu gekommen
sind sondern alle expertinnen und
experten sind dadurch dazu gekommen weil
wir durch wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
in der lage waren
impfungen anzubieten und sicher die
hälfte der gewonnenen lebensjahre
sind darauf zurückzuführen dass wir in
tumen haben und zum zweiten dass wir
zugang für breite masse der bevölkerung
zu diesen impfungen durchsetzen können
und sie sagt das jetzt ganz bewusst
durch sozialdemokraten wurden wir wollen
es nicht nur an aber wir haben immer
darum gekämpft dass alle menschen zugang
zu medizinischen leistungen haben und
auch zugang zu diesen punkt und machen
sie sich die arbeit suchen sie sich
länder in der welt aus kann man bei
wikipedia gutmachen schauen sie schauen
wo haben die menschen die kraft dem
zugang zu impfungen hat zu haben und wo
nicht und dann schaut euch bittet die
lebenserwartung an und da wird man
erkennen dass impfen eine ganz wichtige
sache ist damit man die lebenserwartung
steigert und ich sage jetzt so sagt sie
zu zahlen in österreich
da braucht man nichts statistik studiert
haben geht's zur statik die statistik
austria und schaut euch nur die
todeszahlen die in österreich an wir
haben
2020 um 8.000 mehr tote gehabt
als die jahre davor im durchschnitt und
wir haben sogar im jahr
2021 um 6.000 mehr tote gehabt als die
jahre davor
und das kann es nicht sein und die sagte
sagt sp internen kritikern die uns
umgibt dafür diskutieren müssen worum
geht's mit der regierung mit
sorge schaut die regierung hat es nicht
verdient dass man mit geringen aber
wisst wer sie es verdient hat die
menschen in österreich haben sie es
verdient dass man soll endlich
außer kommen und wir haben
wir haben einige dinge jahr recht und
ich sage es noch einmal impfen ist auch
eine pflicht in der demokratie gibt es
auch pflichten die menschen für sich in
anspruch nehmen möchten oder die man
auch von ihnen verlangen kann wir haben
einiges verbessert wir haben spaß am
arbeitsplatz passt wir haben einige
dinge dazu gemacht minister und
versprochen das 3g am arbeitsplatz
bleibt das ist uns wichtig wir haben
sehr klar gesagt die in konkrete bleiben
wir stehen dazu wir haben sehr klar
gesagt wir stehen zur verantwortung und
ich bring daher auch einen
entschließungsantrag der abgeordneten
rainer wimmer christoph davids magister
markus kurzer betreffend impfpflicht am
arbeitsplatz ein der nationalrat wolle
beschließen der nationalrat ist der
auffassung dass das bestehende arbeits
und
sozialversicherungsrechtliche regelungen
und ansprüche durch das kogit 19
impfpflicht gesetz unberührt bleiben der
bundesminister für soziales gesundheit
pflege und konsumentenschutz wird daher
ersucht dass die aktuell am 20 jänner 22
in der 619 schutzmaßnahmen verordnung
gelten die 3g regelung für arbeitsorte
bzw 2,5 g regelung für mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter von alten und
pflegeheimen
stationären wohne einrichtungen der
behindertenhilfe
krankenanstalten und gestalten und 20
minuten an denen gesundheits
dienstleistungen erbracht werden
beibehalten werden und die allenfalls
dafür die erforderlichen tests
unentgeltlich bleiben das ist das was
die österreichische bevölkerung braucht
wissen dank
der entschließungsantrag wurde vom
abgeordneten stöger ordnungsgemäß
eingebracht steht daher auch mit in
verhandlung und die nächste rednerin ist
die frau abgeordnete gabriela schwarz
vielen dank frau präsidentin mitglieder
der bundesregierung hohes haus liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen vor allem aber
liebe zuseherinnen und zuseher ich
möchte zwei gedanken aufgreifen die
heute schon mehrmals gefallen sind das
eine ist der begriff der solidarität
ja wir pochen auf ein solidarisches
gesundheitssystem aber jahres sollten
auch für dieses solidarische
gesundheitssystem etwas leisten es geht
bei der impfung nicht nur um den
individual- schutz es geht auch um den
schutz der gemeinschaft und wenn ich mir
vorstelle dass menschen keinen termin
für eine op bekommen die dringend
notwendig ist warten müssen weil wir zu
viele menschen haben die am kobelt
erkrankt sind die ungeimpften kobelt
erkrankt sind dann mache ich mir da
meine gedanken und ich sehe es auch so
dass es in der demokratie nicht nur
rechte gibt sondern auch pflichten wir
haben auch die pflicht einander zu
schützen das verstehe ich auch von
deiner moralischen verpflichtung ich
schütze mich und ich schütze mein
gegenüber und wenn wir das rad der zeit
zurückdrehen um ein jahr wo die impfung
das erste mal wirklich großes thema
wurde dann ist er gleich die debatte
aufgekommen um die sicherheit es war
immer völlig klar es ist keine not
zulassung das nochmal klarzustellen es
ist eine bedingte zulassung und das
heißt nichts anderes als dass sich die
ganze welt darauf konzentriert hat
permanent ein gemeldet hat bei der
arzneimittelbehörde und das ebenso im
laufe dieses prozesses immer wieder
überprüft wurde die impfstoffe die von
der eu genehmigt vom national ins
gremium freigegeben und in österreich
sind sicherer können sie darauf
vertrauen dass zum thema impfstoffe auf
der anderen seite zu impfskepsis mittels
sehr gut gefallen was der kollege
jacques gesagt hat zu impfskepsis ich
bin alt genug das ist bei mir noch keine
masern impfung bad und ich bin ein maß
an fast gestorben
sind 84 ist ein maß und nun sind sie ins
programm aufgenommen worden gott sei
dank ähnlich fsme in der fünften klasse
gymnasium wurden wir einfach geimpft und
ja es gab nebenwirkungen aber was war
das ziel uns zu schützen und nichts
anderes tun wir jetzt auch und ich weiß
nicht für welchen gesundheitsausschuss
die kollegin fürst war ich war
offensichtlich bei einem anderen
expertinnen hearing weil sowohl der
primarius semester als auf struktur in
ramadi ganz deutlich gemacht haben diese
impfung schützt auch bei nikon menschen
die zweimal geimpft sind und
aufgefrischt sind haben einen wesentlich
besseren schutz bis zu 90 prozent als
denen gegenüber die nicht geimpft sind
und unser ziel sollte sein es wurde
heute schon mehrmals gesagt ohne
chronist jetzt präsent aber das wird was
wir jetzt tun ist vorsorge zu treffen
für das was noch kommt im zuge der
pandemie hat auch die wissenschaft immer
wieder dinge revidiert und dazugelernt
ich vertraue der wissenschaft und den
erkenntnissen die expertinnen und
experten die jetzt bei dem prozess mit
dabei waren bei der entstehung dieses
gesetzes gemeinsam ärztinnen
juristischen und ich möchte mich da
ausdrücklich nochmals bedanken ich kann
mich an die ersten gespräche mit pamela
rendi wagen am perthel rising erinnern
für die große zusammenarbeit für das
konstruktive es wurde auch immer
kontroversiell diskutiert aber das
ändert nichts an der tatsache dass wir
ein ziel gemeinsam haben unsere freiheit
wieder zurück zu bekommen und das
schaffen wir wenn wir die
durchimpfungsrate die impfquote wirklich
anheben das muss unser gemeinsames ziel
sein und ich möchte sie alle wirklich
von herzen bitten machen sie mit
vertrauen sie der wissenschaft vertrauen
sie ihren ihrem arzt ihrer ärztin und
vertrauen sind nicht dem was sie in
irgendwelchen dubiosen
social media netzwerken lesen sondern
wenden sie sich direkt an die menschen
die das wissen tatsächlich haben das ist
mein appell an sie das ist meine bitte
an sie denn ich bin zutiefst davon
überzeugt dass wir es mit benötigen
durchimpfungsrate gemeinsam wesentlich
besser durch die pandemie schaffen und
wesentlich besser gerüstet sind und
unsere freiheit dann wieder bekommen
herzlichen dank
nächster redner herr abgeordneter hannes
amesbauer
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
regierungsmitglieder geschätzte damen
und herren hier die kollegin schwarz
oder sowie viele wiederum das völlig
falsche aus meiner sicht völlig falsche
solidaritäts argument beim erhöht zum
einen frau kollegin schwarz solidarität
ist nicht dann solidarität wenn es unter
zwang geschieht es ist das erste und das
zweite ist über solidarität könnten
unter umständen reden wenn der impfung
auch eine sterile immunität verleihen
würde wie das zum beispiel bei der
masernimpfung die sie angesprochen haben
und wir froh sein können dass es so
schön finden dann auch gibt ja auch
haben aber hier ist es bekanntlich nicht
der fall aber ich wollte eigentlich
meine rede mit etwas anderen beginnen
nämlich ein eine frage an jene
abgeordneten und jene kollegen die heute
dieses ermächtigungsgesetz hier
durchpeitschen werden geschätzte
kollegen was glauben sie eigentlich wer
sie sind was glauben sie wer sie sind
was machen sie sich an das ist keine des
service international aber das ist keine
über üblichen gesetzen eine
demokratische märz entscheiden wo dann
ein beschlusses der anerkannt ist und
punktet ist das ist eine anmaßung sie
reden sich ein dass recht zu haben über
die körper anderer menschen zu
entscheiden das ist ja keine
mehrheitsentscheidung die körperliche
integrität meine damen und herren das
recht auf körperliche unversehrtheit ist
ein menschenrecht und ein medizinischer
eingriff und das ist ja wohl auch die
impfung ist ausschließlich auf grundlage
der persönlichen und freien entscheidung
des individuums zulässig des einzelnen
menschen was sie hier machen ist
anmaßend ist überheblich und auch
unehrenhafte seinen einmal ins stammbuch
geschrieben
und jetzt kommen ja in ihrer fraktion
immer auch neue begrifflichkeiten dazu
alle von ihnen vom bundeskanzler abwärts
bemühen jetzt die freiheit wir erlangen
alle unsere freiheit durch die
impfpflicht zurück wenn meine damen und
herren übrigens bundeskanzler hat den
interessiert die parlamentsdebatte zu
diesem historischen und weitreichenden
beschluss überhaupt nicht genauso wie
200.000 stellungnahmen nicht
interessieren wenn hunderttausende
friedliche demonstranten nicht
interessieren und wie sie alle scheint
auch die unzähligen mails nicht
interessieren besorgter bürger ich bin
jetzt vier jahre in diesem haus ich habe
noch nie so viele mails bekommen wie in
den letzten zwei tagen haben wir
überraschend viele ärzte dabei und wenn
sie die mails lesen würden und sich die
mühe machen würden die auch zu
beantworten wüssten sie was die menschen
bewegt aber sie ignorieren die menschen
es ist ihnen völlig egal sie in ihre
agenda durch sagen sie mal welche agenda
das ist eine gesundheits ag da kann es
nicht sein meine damen und herren
und weil sie alle sagen ja als der
impfung bringt uns die freiheit zurück
impfen ist freiheit krieg ist frieden
freiheit ist sklaverei
unwissenheit ist stärke wir das sind wir
bei george orwell meine damen und herren
und wie bei allen werden begriffe völlig
in ihrer bedeutung
umgekehrt und wie bei orwell wollen uns
ausgerechnet die freiheits räuber und
unterdrückter erklären dass nur ihre
repressalien uns die freiheit bringen
meine damen und herren grundrechte sind
nicht verhandelbar grundrechte er impft
man sie nicht sie sind unteilbar
unveräußerlich und nicht positionierbar
sie teilen unsere grundrechte sie machen
sie zu zeitlich befristeten privilegien
das gilt für alle die gesamte
bevölkerung ist davon betroffen
und die privilegien bekommen jene
zeitlich befristet wie ein gewünschtes
staatliches vom staat gewünschtes
verhalten setzen meine damen und herren
da reden wir nicht mehr von einer
drohkulisse eines sozial kreditsystems
nach kommunistisch chinesischen vorbild
wir haben das sozial kreditsystem in
österreich das ist real dank ihrer
politik meine damen und herren und
gleichzeitig können wir nach über 2
gegen kraft wo
unzählige
unbescholtenen bürger aus dem
öffentlichen leben komplett ausgegrenzt
werden wir haben nach wie vor die
ausgangs beschränkungen im kraft über
eine million menschen betroffen sind und
zu wissen genau herr gesundheitsminister
das widerspricht auch dem grundsatz der
situation in den spitälern das
widerspricht dem eigenen stufenplan das
ist verfassungswidrig und somit sind
diese ausgangs beschränkungen auch im
regal und all das und jetzt kommt noch
der impfzwang und all das passiert auf
grundlage eines nur behaupteten einer
nur behaupteten gesundheitsgefährdung
für die allgemeinheit meine damen und
herren und sie sagen ja auch immer die
durchimpfungsrate führt zur entlastung
des gesundheitssystems und das mache ich
ihnen auch einen vorschlag ich bringe
einen entschließungsantrag ein der
abgeordneten kickl am sv betreffen das
soll stopp jetzt wir wissen ja dass eine
im vorjahr 40.000 asylanträge gestellt
wurde die kommen her zahlen keinen cent
ein und belasten auch das
gesundheitswesen und reimann dessen
einspruch der nationalrat wolle
beschließen die bundesregierung wird
aufgefordert zum schutz des
österreichischen des 100 systems und der
österreichischen bürger sofort einen
asyl stopp umzusetzen indem begrenzen
wirklich gesichert werden und keine
migranten mehr nach österreich kommen
oder geschleppt werden können meine
damen und herren das ist auch eine
sinnvolle aufgabe für die polizei
missbrauchen sie nicht die polizei hören
sie auf diesen keil zwischen polizei und
bevölkerung nein zu treiben die
polizisten sind bürgern ungefähren das
sind mütter das sind väter und sie
missbrauchen die polizei zu einer völlig
tätigkeit fremden aufgabe dass jeder
bürger per bus triert werden muss von
der polizei und nachdem
gesundheitsstatus abgeklopft werden wird
das ist unrecht und dass es für die
gesellschaft völlig wertlos meine damen
und herren so darf die
polizeigewerkschaft so wir sehen wie
meine damen und herren abschließend
diejenigen abgeordneten die dieses
ermächtigungsgesetz finden mückstein der
dann mit ermächtigungen die intervalle
stetig ändern kann den genesenen status
ändern kann und herumfuhrwerken kann wie
wir das gehört am sie machen heute einen
schweren fehler sie unterstützen den
wortbruch der regierung kategorisch
ausgeschlossen hat dass es keine
impfpflicht gibt sie unterstützen die
ermächtigungen für mückstein und sie
könnten sich eigentlich ein beispiel
nehmen auch an unseren nachbarn
tschechien die impfpflicht abgeschafft
haben mit der begründung dass die gräben
in der bevölkerung nicht weiter vertieft
werden sie machen genau das gegenteil
sie orientieren sich lieber an
tadschikistan und an durch ministern
zwei islamistisch geprägte autoritäre
systeme sie machen einen schweren fehler
meldet ein mann den wir als gesellschaft
wir alle noch bitter bereuen werden
herr abgeordneter der arme bauer für die
bezeichnung zur benennung offensichtlich
an die ab einzelne abgeordnete
gerichtete
formulierung freiheits räuber und
unterdrücker teile ich ihnen natürlich
einen ordnungsruf aber ihr
entschließungsantrag ist ordnungsgemäß
angebracht und steht mit den
verhandlungen herr abgeordneter gerald
lorca sie sind an bord
dankeschön frau präsidentin gesetzte
mitglieder bundesregierung hohes haus
nun ich bin ein klarer befürworter des
impfens ich bin selbst drei mal geimpft
und ich glaube gehöre ich zur großen
mehrheit in dem haus ich gehört zur
minderheit derer die heute nicht für die
impfpflicht stimmen werden wir möchten
dass auch darlegen warum auch in unserem
club bei allen argumenten für die
impfung auch argumente gegen die
impfpflicht abgewogen worden sind vor
einem jahr haben noch alle parteien
unisono versprochen und auch das
gesundheitsministerium es wird keine
impfpflicht geben und man muss sehr gut
aufpassen wenn man solche versprechen
bricht man darf sich nachher nicht
wundern wenn die menschen das vertrauen
in die politik verlieren wir wissen eine
sicher für die omikron welle kommt die
impfung zu spät
und für die zeit danach wissen wir ganz
vieles nicht und damit für die zeit
danach eine impfung verhält eine
impfpflicht verhältnismäßig ist müssen
mehrere annahmen zusammen treffen damit
sich das überhaupt richtig ausgeht erste
annahme es muss eine weitere corona
variante kommen die aggressiver ist als
die omikron variante aber die omikron
variante alleine bringt das
gesundheitssystem nicht zum erliegen
varianten werden aber tendenziell eher
milder bei viren als aggressiver zweite
annahme
sektionschefin raich hat gesagt das
virus führt zu einer durchseuchung
aber das muss dann heißen dass diese
durch sei und keinerlei immunisierung
wirkung bei der bevölkerung hinterlässt
und quasi wenn dann eine weitere
variante kommt die sowie auf eine
medizinische naive bevölkerung trifft
die keine ein grundschutz hat das ist
wenig realistisch anzunehmen und eine
weitere dritte annahme muss auch zu
treffen nämlich dass die impfstoff für
die wir heute haben und heute verwenden
und im februar märz april sehr impfen
dann auch für zukünftige varianten
überhaupt greifen und das ist ungewiss
und weil das alles ungewiss ist dass man
mit diesem gesetz eine überlastung des
gesundheitswesens verhindern kann
handelt es sich um einen
grundrechtseingriff auf vorrat und das
ist für mich überschießend jetzt schon
ein grundrechte einzugreifen für einen
fall von dem wir noch gar nicht weiß
oder eintritt vor allem aber und das
sind jetzt wieder bei einem punkt der
außer streit steht die österreichische
bürokratie kann das gar nicht umsetzen
es ist ja nicht nur so dass die polizei
sagt wir wollen das nicht machen und die
polizeigewerkschaft sagt wir können das
nicht die polizei kontrollen führen auch
über die hintertür zu einer
ausweispflicht im alltag die wir bisher
in österreich nicht gekannt haben
die strafverfügung die die
bezirkshauptmannschaften versenden
werden werden mit zehntausenden
einsprüchen wieder zurückkommen und
werden reguläre strafverfahren zur folge
haben das sagen die
bezirkshauptmannschaften und magistrate
wir können das nicht bewältigen und auch
die richter der landes
verwaltungsgerichte sagen wir können das
alles nicht bewältigen wir brauchen 50
prozent mehr verwaltungsrichter um diese
flut an erwartbaren beschwerden zu
schaffen wie wollen sie eine impfpflicht
auf den boden bekommen wenn die behörden
ist nicht schaffen dann sind in diesem
gesetz in 20 paragrafen 7
verordnungsermächtigungen vorgesehen
fünf davon für die gesundheitsminister
ich glaube zur qualität von verordnungen
aus dem gesundheitsministerium muss ich
nicht sagen wir haben davon den letzten
zwei jahren reichlich erlebt das kann
ich nicht weiter unterstützen und man
fragt sich wozu sie die ganzen experten
haben mit denen hören sie nämlich nicht
zu professor kollaritsch der als einer
der oberrhein sperre und lockdown dieser
republik hat gesagt verschieben sie die
impfpflicht unter den auspizien die wert
haben professor nowotny hat gestern in
der auch nicht gerade einer der für
lockerungen eintritt hat gestern in der
zib2 auf die frage gesagt ist nach
omikron eigentlich dann krone wie eine
grippe und er sagt absolut also sie
führen eine impfpflicht ein für eine
erkrankung von der professorin sagt dass
nachher wie eine grippe professor
gartlehner auch immer sehr
regierungsseitig unterwegs hat gesagt
ihr mann sollte angesichts der omicron
variante die impfpflicht noch einmal
überdenken und jetzt kommt eine ganz
spannende person dem dfb vorsteht
vorwirft hätte ein großes geschäfts
hinterlässt sind nämlich das schiff von
kaiser albert burla und was hat der im
französischen fernsehen gesagt die
omikron welle ist die letzte welle die
solche einschränkungen notwendig macht
das wird nachher nicht mehr notwendig
sein
pfizer-chef wird der nicht gegen das
eigene geschäft reden wenn es gefährlich
wer würde da das schon sagen aber selbst
dir sagt so wie es bisher war wird es
nicht mehr sein und was machen sie jetzt
für uns nicht nur eine impfpflicht ein
sondern am selben tag eine infanterie
also jetzt schlittens eine milliarde aus
an leute die sich an ein gesetz halten
es wird bekommt man schon geld wenn man
sich an ein gesetz hält also wie
verrückt ist es geworden sie können auch
geld ausschütten an die die bei einer
ampel bei rot stehen bleiben die hat sie
als gesetzt ich bin sehr für simpson ich
bin dreimal geimpft die impfungen helfen
uns die schützen die spital kapazitäten
der intensivbetten vor einer überlastung
aber eine impfpflicht hilft nicht sie
spaltet die gesellschaft sie greift
unnötigen grundrechte ein und alle
politiker versprochen diese impfpflicht
kommt nicht jetzt kommt sie doch und sie
verspielen das vertrauen der menschen in
die politik
[Applaus]